yeah
I couldn't it was like I couldn't win if
I didn't do anything
um if I didn't say anything to him about
the drinking if I didn't acknowledge it
it got worse if I did acknowledge it it
was my fault and I was nagging
and I get it um you know I wouldn't like
to be told what to do either so but it
made him really angry and the kids were
in in the on this press tour and I was
just concerned about them I was
concerned about them hearing us
Tony screamed at me in the hotel room
and only to think where the kids were in
an adjoining room
what if they could hear us you know I
had just met them and I didn't want them
to think
poorly at me
and hate me not knowing what was going
on you know in our buying closed doors I
I just um
I remember and
it was name calling and he eventually
passed out do you recall what names he
called you do you recall what he said uh
I heard at this time nagging [ __ ]
nagging [ __ ] all the time called me
[ __ ]
uh he even said that he made a mistake
uh with me and
that he didn't want to that when we
touched back down
he'd get rid of me and I'd go back to
you said some disgusting things to me I
don't know if I need to repeat it okay
let's go look Michelle can you bring up
defendants exhibit 1090
you indicated I think that he passed out
at the end of that
did you take this picture I did okay uh
your honor I'd like to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 1090 no
objection here thank you zero nine zero
in evidence you can publish
thank you
and and where was
Mr Depp when you took this picture
uh he was passed out with his head and a
table in the hotel room uh in our our
hotel room not the kids hotel room
um in Tokyo
on that press store
all right now I'm going to take you to
August 2013. what if any discussions did
you start having with Mr Deb about
moving in with him
well
after
you know after this I
I was getting close to his kids
and he had a stint of sobriety aft
shortly after that
and it felt really good again and
shortly after that he started um
suggesting that I
let him rent my apartment for the
vultures that's what he called the press
and he said now that we were like a
known couple now that it was out in the
press that my apartment wasn't like safe
effectively for for me and I you know I
had a modest apartment
in Los Angeles and so he started
uh
saying I needed to have Security on me
or we'd bring out the neighboring the
neighboring houses because of the
vultures and it was a conversation and
then that conversation evolved into
I should move in with him
um
you know always wanted me to go with his
security guards wanted me to have his
credit card obviously I wouldn't accept
that but the conversation about moving
in became
um you know hard to resist because I was
increasingly becoming a part of his life
and also
loving his
loving his family and feeling like you
know more stability would mean more
stability with him and his struggles
with drug and alcohol abuse I mean use
and I thought I would
minimize some of the jealousy and
insecurity that he had it was
hard for me to work justify working
every audition every meeting every
script I got was a
negotiation or a fight I had to justify
it like
as if I was saying hey let's have an
open relationship it was you know and I
thought that would be minimized if I
could
make him feel more secure but you know
if we leave live together certainly
there would be more security right and
that was my reasoning
so you talked about still reading
scripts and things what if anything did
you do differently in terms of pursuing
your acting career
well I've always
I've always been really
I've always
been really independent you know and
I've never imagined not working I've
worked from the earliest time I can
imagine I
come from you know parents who
worked until they literally couldn't
anymore you know I I never
imagined myself
having to
explain my job or Justify my job but I
did you know and I am independent and I
see myself as independent
and strong-willed and I had to bargain
every time I get a script it would be
you know I thought you weren't taking
another job I'd always say are you
kidding me that's crazy I have to work I
support my family you know when I moved
out to LA I'd get a check for you know a
gig 600 or something I say path for me
send half to my family
you know I I kept having to justify
taking work by saying I'm supporting my
parents you know I'm supporting my
sister I'm supporting my family I have
to work
and he would say you don't have to work
kid let me take care of you my woman
doesn't have to work
and that sounds really sweet and really
romantic in in some way but it became a
real fight you know every time
I got a script it was what kind of you
know how I was dressing what kind of
behavior I'd have what how did I have a
sex scene and then I started saying no I
won't take the sex scenes or you know
I'll take the part where I don't play
you know that kind of character or then
I started minimizing the kinds of
kissing scenes that I had and eventually
I had to change the Wardrobe that I
could have in in the movie I couldn't
have a
couldn't have a sex scene but that all
you know was it didn't happen all at
once of course it was a little thing
after a little thing after little thing
and eventually I found myself
pushing as many scripts off my desk as I
could picking the ones that had minimal
makeup dress can as conservative as
possible
finding ways to
minimize the scenes I had where I had a
romantic involvement of any kind it was
just it was a constant battle and
negotiation
so let me take you back did you as a
result of your discussions with Mr Depp
about moving in did there come a time
that you did move in with him objection
leading
overruled thank you uh yes
please and let me ask you this you've
talked about pentat we've heard a little
bit about Penthouse appointments and and
Suites here could you just explain to
the jury the
different places that Mr Depp had in Los
Angeles and what they were called just
so we have some context here when we're
going through all this
it's a little
confusing I imagine
um he had about I think four or five
mansions in this beautiful
like you know border of Beverly Hills in
West Hollywood and they were all in a
cul-de-sac and we called it tweets her
because that was the name of the street
and there are five houses I think five
houses it could be four all you know
effectively he had the whole street
then he had about five penthouses
downtown on the same floor of the
Eastern Columbia building which you've
heard about the ECB
and sweetzer was
you know Johnny's
Kingdom
uh one of those houses was like a whole
house was his man cave it was a studio
and it was where you made music and hung
out
um and we spent some time in there but
that was effectively Johnny's
you know place and then there was the
the downtown places and they were
effectively empty saved for some
furniture and one of Johnny's friends
Isaac
uh who you met
and he lived there
um at some point before uh Johnny and I
eventually decided to move in together
let me just stop you there I just want
to make sure we're clear are we talking
about the penthouses or are we talking
about Suites here Isaac lived in the
penthouses the rest of them were about
pretty much empty and my best friend
um who I was very very very very close
to uh went through a breakup and he very
kindly uh insisted on moving her into
this Penthouse and of course she said no
for the first few times but he insisted
and said they were empty and he would
love to have her move down there and he
very kindly move my best friend downtown
Rocky yeah Rocky Pennington but the
problem is it's like 30 45 minutes from
West Hollywood where my place was which
we call Orange
at the time okay
so when did when did you move in to the
penthouses shortly after he moved Rocky
my best friend into the penthouse so she
was in one of these empty
ish apartments and
um and somewhere around that time
I
I might I think it took me some time
actually but after that I eventually
agreed to move in with him and give up
my place although that made me pretty
nervous
um to be honest but we
were in this relationship that was very
serious and we were constantly traveling
also as another part of it is we were in
La for a matter of days or weeks I'd go
do a job he'd go do a job I'd come back
for a photo shoot or a red carpet go on
a location go visit him on a location
and there was an incredible amount of
travel movement so we weren't really
again living the day-to-day that you
might normally with a partner you know
where you have a home and you move in
together and you have one home
we didn't have that it was
okay very different I'm going to take
you to September of
2013. what were you filming at that time
London Fields
yes that's right okay I was filming
London Fields I just started all right
did there come a time that you were
became engaged to Mr Depp
well
yeah it was difficult because in that
that role was a like a very difficult
role I I mean every every time
every scene that involved sexuality or
romance was like
I'd look at that on the page and it felt
like a you know I'd feel my gut tighten
because I knew
it was going to be an issue uh but
Johnny dropped me off he he
I gave him the script I sent him
pictures of what I was wearing in my
wardrobe fittings I sent him everything
um I shared his script my script with
his um his team
and uh the fighting eventually kind of
minimized I it was clear I was going to
do this job
and I told myself I had I had to do this
job and Johnny had to go to London I
think for some pre-production stuff for
a movie he was going to do a smaller
part in I think it was called I think
this was into the woods is my best guess
so he dropped me off in London and when
he dropped me off in London we had a few
days
at this hotel that
we first
you know like consummated our
relationship in you know as a when we
were on the London press tour
and our relationship
developed
um that was the same hotel we were in
this same room which is a Johnny
like to be in the same room
and it was really sweet he got down on
one knee and
said I want you to be my girl be my girl
forever My Woman My Girl
I want you to be the rest of my life say
yes to me
he said he wanted to spend every
every day uh
he promised me that every day when I
woke up that I would wake up and he
would make me smile at least once
and that would be his goal
and
you know I I looked into
his eyes and I saw
my future
hope you know like blind hope so in love
it was one of the most
I can't describe that kind of joy you
know I thought
you know if we were married then
this is real this is real this isn't a
thing of
this isn't chaotic and this will change
you know I just I had so much hope in
that moment
um and I just said to him over and over
again are you serious are you are you
serious are you sure because you didn't
have a ring so I thought is this an
Impulse thing you know my experience
Johnny could be very impulsive and
uh he
uh he said over and over again be my be
my be my woman forever I want you to be
my wife my wife my wife
um I of course cried and we had a
wonderful evening and I still he left
shortly after and I was like the next
day I had to go to work and I was just I
couldn't tell anyone and I wasn't sure
part of me was worried that he didn't
mean it or you know or or that he wasn't
sure I just didn't want it to be an
Impulse thing so I didn't want to
mention it I want to bring it up I
didn't want to
um and and I kind of felt I walked
around for a few days like I had
butterflies
under my skin and
then my he brought my dad out to London
with my best friends and my dad told me
you know uh
Johnny is asked me permission for your
hand in marriage
and
I I felt like the luckiest woman in the
world
so while you were filming London Fields
and Johnny had gone back to L.A what if
any issues did you have with him on
fraternizing with the cast
I'm going to ask Michelle can you pull
up defendant's exhibit 188 please
your honor I'm going to object on here
say
you're honor I'm going to let's pull up
188 a I've redacted everything but what
Mr Depp says all right a 188 a that's a
mission against interest
do you have that you don't have it
while they're working on that can you
tell us what transpired
between you and Mr Depp when you wanted
to do something with a cast member
so
as I said he came
to London for his own work and also
dropped me he dropped me off in London
where I had to be for a few months to
film this movie
and uh he asked me to marry him he
brought my my best friends and my dad
out they left
and shortly after they left
um my co-star one of my co-stars invited
me to go to a concert with him and some
of the cast to kind of break the ice and
I'd be working with them for the next
few months
and I had already you know I already
knew I couldn't like be photographed
even if it was platonic I couldn't be
photographed with men or women that
other people could possibly spin as
romantic
I had learned that
but in January the hard way
um
so I asked him permission
if I could go to this concert
uh with the cast
and I you know I said you know Johnny
that like he's gonna the my coach
Direction your honor here say
don't tell us what the co-star said just
tell us what your communication was with
Mr debb objection hearsay her
Communications are here say
okay I'll sustain the objective I'm not
sure I understand if you want to
approaches yes
that if I
except that accepted the invitation and
went out to a concert that the
engagement would be off that the
relationship would be off
and that I was uh
foolish
naive
for thinking that
people could invite me to a concert in a
platonic way I tried to say that it was
function hearsay
is she's testified about what Mr debb
said I don't understand all right I'll
overrule that objection please continue
um yeah he said I was foolish and naive
that no one could invite me
to how could I be so dumb to think that
somebody could just invite me to a
concert why would they want to hang out
with me obviously it was because
they wanted
more for me and that I probably wanted
more too you know
um I was basically asking for it you're
going to go backstage what are you going
to say to the band and then I know how
this plays out and who's you know who's
the other girl gonna be there and how
could you be so stupid how could you be
so foolish or more naive you should be
smarter than this
and I
apologized I stayed I mean that whole
evening I think for a few hours I spent
on the phone with him texting calling or
talking hanging up he'd hang up on me be
upset
and then send me cryptic messages about
my
my foolishness and you know I'm already
doing a movie where I play this
you know character
when I you know where I was in power
like I read the script and I thought
this character was empowered sexually
and by the time
I got Johnny's feedback on it I had been
convinced that actually I was just being
used that it I I was just being used it
was clear that that was all I had to
offer and I was too foolish to see it
and I had I'm just going to stop you
right there because I'd like you to take
a look at defendant 60 but 188 a is that
in front of you do you recognize this
portion of the text chain chain between
you and Mr Depp
yes I do okay and this is on September 9
2013.
yes it is okay and are these statements
Mr Depp made to you during that evening
that you just described to the jury yes
your honor I'm going to move the
admission of defendants 188 a
any objection no objection 188 a in
evidence as redacted do I have that
reduction or is that something you need
to give me I think we're going to need
to give it to you a hard copy all right
thank you thank you
and if I
and if I can draw your attention to it
uh he he first says I don't want to make
anything an issue baby but I literally
have been on the ground just 14 [ __ ]
hours from leaving your side do you see
that yes and then he says you know what
I want who I am and where I want to go
with us
you know very well what type of [ __ ]
man I am and yet you lay a gauntlet
before me that you know
is the very species the danger that will
always attract me into a very tempting
test what's behind that door
almost impossible to even not take you
on
you want me to roll the dice this sounds
more like an aggravated ultimatum than
soft words that could help us make both
feel better don't test me please did he
tell you that yes he did what did you
understand that to me
uh it was clear
um it was a threat a threat that if I
wanted to be objection speculation
I think she can say what she understood
it to mean I'll sustain the objection
okay
all right let's move on then to the
filming of Mordecai with Mr Bethany in
October November 2013.
where did that take place
in London okay and what if any
involvement did you have were you there
for any part of that filming
for part of it I happen to be in London
already for the film I was just telling
you about and Johnny came to London
shortly after to film
um his own movies he did the smaller I
think it was a smaller role
um and into the woods and then he was
filming Mordecai after that so
um after
after I finished my movie I moved in
with him uh into his house in London a
rented house in London
okay and
describe your experiences during that
time period
with Mr Depp
it was
it was really touch and go he was
filming with
Paul Bettany and
there were days when
um
he wouldn't come home or they couldn't
get him up out of
on set he'd be asleep in his trailer
sleeping whatever he'd done the night
before off
um I remember he missed a few days of
work that way I it struck me because in
in my experience in our job
you you don't miss work
it doesn't matter how sick you are you
you go you know it's millions of dollars
every single day they're filming and and
I had not experienced
someone who could effectively just
control the set like that you know I
mean to that extent and
one day he didn't come home
and I was worried sick
um I found out that he was in a hotel
room with public objection hearsay okay
okay move forward because when he came
home they had to carry him home
objection hearsay did you see that I
watched it okay
go ahead okay please continue I I
watched
um actually I was I was shocked that he
could do it one of the security guards
carried
carried Johnny like a baby
into the house and I looked at that and
I mean his his boots were hanging over
the security guard's arm who had to
negotiate getting through the doorway
carrying Johnny like this and I thought
I watched this
his assistants and the other security
Arts shaking their head you know just
shaking their head acknowledging this is
how bad it is and
I remember thinking this has got to be
it like this has got a
change this is surely this is it
and he was
understandably very very sick for
at least two days is my recollection
um
and in that two days I had a lot of
conversations with this team I won't say
what they were
um but I would
felt at that juncture very encouraged
that everybody
and myself were on the same page and I
felt encouraged that we were in a new
chapter that Johnny had finally
hit rock bottom and finally he felt like
changing for good and I I felt buoyed
you know supported by these
conversations I was having with people
that he was close to that he trusted
November 2013 did you have any contact
with Lily Rose that led to any
discussions with Mr Depp objection
leading what if any connection
Communications did you have with Lily
Rose in November 2013. objection
cultures hearsay leading
I'm asking what her connection was I
didn't ask what she said let me sustain
the objection okay uh
November 2013 uh what if any uh
interaction did you have with Lily Rose
without saying anything she said
objection hearsay
it's interaction your honor I'm not
asking for what she said
if you can lay a foundation out
did there come a
did there come a time in November 2013
that you saw Lily Rose
yes they came to stay with us for some
time in the winter yeah around November
I believe 2013. when you said they were
you referring to uh Johnny's kids uh
Jack and Lily Rose all right and was
there a particular incident that led to
uh
disagreement with Mr Depp
Jackson leading
stain what a fanny interaction did you
have with Lily Rose that led to an
argument with Mr Depp objection leading
that what if any
approach
did you have an argument with Mr Depp
relating to Lily Rose in November 2016.
yes can you please describe that
well he I
I didn't I was I I was
you know these kids were
I found them to be these beautiful
wildly intelligent little
weirdos in the best way you know they
were
I I was falling in love with them
and
you know they
were in my life at that time a short
amount of time but I I I loved it and I
felt I started to feel very protective
and
you know uh Johnny sobriety meant that
he was there and then he wasn't
and the nature of our lives with the
travel and work meant he was there and
then he wasn't and Lily Rose at some
point
um had a crush on a on a you know
objection hearsay
and lock a foundation
I'll overruled for them thank you please
continue this argument happened because
the Johnny was
I I didn't agree that this gentleman uh
it was a
famous musician over the age of 18.
spent the night at the house
and I felt protective
over Lily Rose and concerned
and naturally they're not they were not
my children it's not my place
and I understand that
I know it's a sensitive subject so I
understand why Johnny got so upset with
me
but that and the introduction of the
weed with his daughter she was so young
I just felt protective
again it's not my place I understand
that and
I made him really angry by weighing in
on that okay
did there come a time that there was a
family engagement
Gathering
well we
celebrated Thanksgiving out in in London
the kids were there
um
there was a
a stent of sobriety
following how sick he got on on set with
Paul Bettany
[Music]
um
after a one of his drug binges and he
kind of just came alive again you know
um he even like pray to played a prank
on me uh about having like relapsed when
he what he hadn't relapsed you know it
was I started to kind of feel that with
the kids being around I kind of thought
I did think that maybe this was it we
were on a a good path
meaning so to sobriety that this was it
and
our life was
peaceful for a minute you know it was
it went back to being wonderful
there were these moments it just felt so
One Direction you're on or
non-responsive
sustain the objection okay
take us to the engagement there was this
engagement party correct uh then yes
come Christmas
uh of 2013 Johnny had rented this
beautiful mansion in Malibu
on the beach it was gorgeous
and he brought my family out and his
family was out obviously in LA and we
stayed in this rented mansion and
we're all together for the holidays and
uh it it went one evening we were going
to his mother's house his mother who
you've heard about uh was old older and
sick but at home being cared for and he
when one evening we're going to have
dinner Christmas dinner there with with
her around the time of her birthday as
well and my best friend said you should
rejection hearsay sorry it wasn't
offered to prove the truth of the matter
but but go ahead and go past that what
did you do we went to Betty Sue's house
his mother's house and Johnny proposed
in front of our families in this big you
know surprise he surprised me got down
on one knee and and
you know I cried and hugged my mother
and hugged his mother and
he gave me this
enormous diamond ring and
it was it was a nice time
I'm gonna take you into January February
2014.
[Music]
um you had as you employed a woman named
Kate James is that correct protection
leading
what if any relationship did you have
with Kate James
uh she was my assistant at the time
I hired her sometime in 2012.
and had as minimal uh contact with her
as I possibly could so
and why and why is that
um
she was
um I
difficulty
um troubled and inconsistent I just
drank on the job and stuff like that and
her behavior was objection relevance
horrible she's already testified Kate
James is testified and I think his bias
uh we can all right I'll allow that go
ahead thank you okay
um
please describe for the jury what you're
what uh
job responsibilities Kate had and how
you communicated with her and kind of
how
that worked we rejection compound
we'd minimal um
person-to-person interaction because I
was hardly ever in La if I was I was
there for a few days at a time and
Johnny and I kind of lived in this
insular bubble anyway
um when we were together
uh but we would send emails uh texts and
voice a lot of voice memos voice notes
uh and
you know if I
I found that if I said Kate you know you
you left the car running with your doors
open and your kids in the car on the
street you actually hearsay
she's not testifying she's testifying
about context sustained objection next
question all right
um I'm going to ask you to take a look
at defendants exhibit 209
your honor I'm going to object on
hearsay grounds
all right
let's still hearsay
did you I I may I lay the foundation
first
just misheard uh did you communicate
with Kate James uh by email in the
ordinary course of your business yes I
did okay and I'm going to ask you to
take a look at defendants 209 is this a
communication that was between you and
Kate James that was in the ordinary
course of business as with her as an
employee
yes it is your honor I'm going to move
the admission of defendants exhibit 209.
business records exceptions still
hearsay your honor
business record exception gets the
business record but these hearsay if
there's hearsay involved inside the
business record that's there's still
objection to hearsay
regarded the business records exception
I mean I do I
I don't agree I think that's the point
that hearsay can approach
foreign
foreign
what if any Communications did you have
with Kate James about your issues with
Mr Depp
objection hearsay Ms James has testified
I'll sustain the objection
all right well we can take that down
Michelle
in the February I'm going to jump to
February March 2016. what if any
Communications did you have with Mr Depp
about a prenup
well after the uh after the engagement
but before the engagement party I
started to
um
I started to
feel like it would make
you know I know that he earned
significantly more than me successful
actor I wanted to eliminate any doubt
and in his mind in in other people's
minds so I brought it up to him
and brought it up to my therapist
um objection hearsay
she's just saying that she brought it up
to her therapist she's not saying what
she said but please focus on Mr Depp
okay of course
um Johnny said he would tear it up
uh if I he said if I if you ever brought
one up to me or if I ever saw one got my
hands on it I'd tear it up only way out
of this is death
only way out of this is death
and I
um I thought it
I thought it would like
I didn't care either way but I did feel
that it would eliminate suspicion or
doubt and it would make things easier
and I told him over and over again you
know are you sure are you sure
maybe maybe we should do this
and he one time he said to me he's like
kid are you already thinking of how
you're getting out of this are you
already planning to get out of this kid
you already you already planning on
leaving
it was that was um the same it was
around the same time as the moving in
together conversation
um it was I he accused me of having one
foot out
um and they kind of were happening
around the same time you know I still
had my apartment and
we were engaged now uh he was
asking me to redecorate uh Switzer his
main house and kind of move into the to
the ECB building downtown where my best
friend was living
um at this time
uh while the decorations and the and the
remodeling had been done on sweet sir
and so these conversations were kind of
happening about how to build our future
together and how we were going to move
forward together and uh I
you know um
I I would have forgotten about the the
extent that we had those conversations
early on in the engagement if it hadn't
been for my therapist notes
I'm sorry if it hadn't been for your
what if it hadn't been for my
therapist's notes taken at the time when
I was talking to her about this and my
conversations with objection hearsay
okay
okay let's take it to March 2014. did
there come a time there was an
engagement party
yes so
um yeah it was March uh 2014. please
subscribe for the jury we had an
engagement party and we decided that
when we did get married would have a
small
wedding you know something intimate but
uh you know our lives were kind of big
and his life was extremely big
uh and we needed to incorporate we
wanted to have a bigger engagement party
than a wedding you know and kind of get
our guests in our family our friends and
have a big a big event of it as opposed
to making the wedding something that was
big and
you know um so we kind of put it on the
engagement party and had
a bunch of people a lot of friends
business acquaintances
um a lot of family I had all of my
family friends and my childhood friends
come out for it and I even invited my
therapist it was you know a big a big
event okay and describe what took place
at the engagement party
uh when we walk in together and we took
some pictures and
said a few hellos and then Johnny
disappeared upstairs uh in I guess it's
like a coat room or something was in a
big abandoned building that was rented
out for events and he disappeared
upstairs
um almost the entire party I would say
uh it was kind of
came down at the end when we were
leaving and came down once because he
was at the time sharing drugs with my
dad objection
speculation
lack of foundation how did you know that
he was sharing drugs with your dad I was
there
I watched it
please continue
um
my dad at the time was uh on the same
was addicted to the same thing Johnny
was
and so my dad had
um either my Dad ran out or Johnny ran
out I can't recall which of the two ran
out but there was a you know they they
needed more of course and had to leave
the party my dad actually left with
Johnny's security to go get more drugs
from Jackson calls for speculation
how do you know that uh they told me
hearsay sustain the objection okay okay
and um they left to go whatever and then
they came back with drugs and everything
was okay in terms of the the withdrawal
symptoms of them I don't know what you
call it at that point but uh he still
um stayed upstairs and referring to Mr
Depp yes I am okay so shortly after that
I tried to get Johnny to come downstairs
[Music]
um
and he just
snapped at me just verbally
um told me to shut the [ __ ] up
and uh
I
I remember talking to my mom about the
irony of it okay we're an engagement
party but that was a pretty
that was pretty much it for the
engagement party and I went downstairs
and entertained guests and smiled and
took pictures and put on a face and you
know went about my evening
would take you to May 2014 the Met Gala
could you please tell the jury what a
Met Gala is and what's involved in that
objection compound
I overruled out
Miguel is a big event annual event uh
celebrity event uh in New York it's a
fashion event but it's it's just a major
red carpet event
and you have to be invited and
it's kind of um
a thing you know and we were invited
that year
and I uh I had already gone for the
previous year or two uh and this year we
were going to go together
and at some point in the evening we're
sitting across the table
and Johnny starts asking me about this
woman
um
he thought I was looking at this woman
in a sexual way and I
kind of
turned it around on him and said that
exact action hearsay all right it's on
text your honor
contact sustain the objection okay just
say what Mr Depp said then I guess you
can't tell us what you said to him okay
uh
he was accusing me of flirting
and that's how the argument started I I
don't recall what other accusations I
was Fielding at that moment but
typically in my experience with him it
wasn't just one
uh so you'd make a point and then he
would
go on to a different accusation
um but I remember that what started it
is this accusation that I had been
flirting at this event uh we get back to
the hotel room
um and Johnny shoves me
and kind of grabs me by the collarbone
area like not really my neck but top of
my neck
top of my above my collarbone below my
neck
um
I I think at that point when we were
still in the living room I shoved him
back
but I can't I don't really recall
um too many specifics I remember he
threw a bottle at me it missed me but it
broke the chandelier
and at some point I remember
um maybe this was
the shove that I was talking about but
at some point uh Johnny and I are in a
struggle in the living room and
kind of like shoves me down on the sofa
and I get up and I'm trying to get him
off of me and it's just stronger than me
I don't know how else to describe it
and at some point and he just whacks me
in the face
and I had not
at the time
been like I didn't I think that was the
first time I was like is this a broken
nose
at the time I was unsure what that
feeling was
um but I suspected I had a broken nose
and other than that I was relatively
unscathed but I remember my nose being
swollen discolored red
and uh I took a picture of my face
at some point and made a joke about it
to my friend about how bad I looked
compared to how objection hearsay
say what you talked what you told a
friend okay okay
um let's take you to
um the Adderall Diaries when did you
start filming the Adderall Diaries
believe
May
I filmed another movie
in New York mar mar March April April
May I went straight from that movie to
another movie independent film with
James Franco
the one I had previously shot was with
Christopher Walken that's right okay so
I went from one to the other
and
um saw Johnny in these you know in
between like if I got a long weekend or
you know I'd fly home to be with him and
then fly back it was kind of like that
fly back from where where were you
filming though in New York okay and
Johnny was in LA at the time and then
eventually went on location for his
movie Black Mass in Boston
so you were New York and Mr Depp was in
Boston at some point eventually in by
May 2014. that's it
if any discussions or arguments did you
have with Mr Depp relating to James
Franco in that time frame of May 2014.
it's a nightmare
um
I wanted to do this independent film I
liked the story I liked the character
I you know told him I'm not going to
wear makeup in the thing Jackson hearsay
apparently it's better if we could
approach please
so tell the jury what Mr Depp said
he was mad at me for taking the job with
James Franco he hated
James Franco
um and was
already accusing me of kind of secretly
having a thing with him in my past since
we had done Pineapple Express together
so I'm going to take you to the Boston
plane
incident we've heard about that earlier
May 24.
can you please describe for the jury
what took place on May 24.
relating to the plane incident
well I
I had spoken to Johnny you know he's in
Boston I'm in New York
and I spoke to him
he had already been upset with me and
accused me in um like many arguments
about not
telling him about scenes that I had if I
had a kissing scene
any sort of romantic scene and I wasn't
explicit about what I was going to do
then I was accused of having withheld
information and hiding it from him
so
I didn't want the fight of course I
didn't want the argument but I had to
kind of eggshell tiptoe around how to
tell him when I had any sort of scene
like that
and I did tell him in this occasion
objection hearsay
take we need to stay with what Mr Depp
said Okay Okay so
he was upset with me
um but he didn't sound coherent
so much on the phone he was
yelling at me about how could you how
could you tell me this how could you
tell me this when I'm filming when I
have this scene that I'm doing how could
you tell me this when I'm working
obviously I couldn't tell any other time
because we were both filming and I told
him as soon as
it was relevant and but he kept saying
how could you tell me this how could you
just tell me this
uh and it was like I had told him I was
having an affair or something you know
it was that angry at me but he kind of
started to sound less connected to
reality as these like arguments would
happen on the phone this is in one day
eventually he hangs up on me in the
conversation
screaming screaming at me
um
I talked to
his assistants I won't say what they
said but I had conversations and felt
encouraged that I could continue on with
the plan which was for me to get on the
plane go to Boston pick him up and we
would go back to LA for his daughter's
birthday
um
I was nervous because the conversation
I'd had with him and he was so upset
with me on that conversation but
I figured he'd I assumed he'd passed out
and that he would have been kind of
sobered up
the next day
assuming that the work would mean that
he felt pressured to to kind of pull it
together
and I uh get on the plane he sent the
plane so I assumed he's not that mad at
me
he's over it
we're moving on he sobered up
um
there had been a lot of talk about a
sober plan like a full detox a full
recovery a doctor a whole plan
you know there were talks of that
following what had happened in London so
I was feeling like okay well maybe we're
here and I get on the plane it touches
down and the SUV pulls up and it sits on
the tarmac for a very long time
he knows I'm on the plane waiting for
him
so I kind of started to anticipate that
things weren't
as I hoped meaning that he was sobering
had sucked it off
and I get I mean I'm sitting on the
plane for a very long time waiting for
him and he finally opens the door and I
see him get out of the SUV and I can
guess by how he's moving how he's
walking
I didn't realize at the time I had
already been become really sensitive to
these little changes
um because my life changed depending on
what he was on
and he gets on the plane and I
um I just knew and every cell of my body
something was wrong
and
he comes straight up to me doesn't say
anything to me but is looking at me he's
got these glasses on and he takes them
off in this kind of aggressive Manner
and sits down across from me not in the
usual spot
we'd kind of have our places on on his
plane you know where you get used to
sitting and he
I remember I got up and moved to
accommodate him getting by so he could
sit in the normal seat as per usual
he didn't set a cross for me
at some point and I don't really
remember the exact sequence of it
we take off and at some point he
he's asking me why what's wrong with me
what do I have do I have something to
tell him do I have something to tell him
you want to talk to me about your day
yesterday and then it gets
I I already know that he's
drunk I already know he's using he reeks
of weed and alcohol I mean his breath
smelled so bad and I could
I I could anticipate that there was a
no-win situation here there was no me
talking myself out of this or talking
him down or any
you know a lot of my arguments and my
involvement in them are me trying to
diffuse by explaining or objection
non-responsive
telling the story yeah
I'll sustain an objectionist that's part
good okay
so he
um is asking me questions and I know to
not engage
uh I was polite I made sure to answer
minimal amount of you know the minimal
amount that I could I moved slowly I was
trying to be polite but not engaged
because there was no win and he kept
going kept asking me eventually went
from do you have something to tell me to
you want to tell me how much you liked
it
tell me did he slip a tongue
it got worse and worse just more it went
from asking me about how my kissing
scene went or how the sex scene went to
asking me what James Franco had done in
the scene to being really explicit about
my body
you know he was talking about
my
saying
really disgusting things
about my body
about how I liked it how I responded and
then he started talking just straight up
taunting me I I know you liked it he
called me a go-getter
um he called me a [ __ ] in front and also
this is happening with security and his
assistance on the plane and
I remember I felt
I I
don't I don't I I struggle to to be able
to tell you how
how embarrassed I was because he was
speaking to me in front of people in
this way
asking me if I liked it and if I was wet
and you know why I wasn't looking at him
and that was proof I wasn't looking at
him that was proof that I that I was
asking for it did I ask
James to do this and this to me and how
about if he does those things to me ex
insert
sexually explicit descriptions of what
he
accuse me of wanting or deserving
and I at some point in this get up
and move to the front of the planet I
remember getting up so slowly I didn't
want to aggravate him I didn't want to
give him any excuse to pounce on I
didn't want to upset him I didn't want
him
to flip a switch and get worse I didn't
want I just remember
very slow movements and I slowly get up
and move to the front of the plane and
he starts throwing things at me ice
cubes utensils
he's calling me a
um a go-getter and then an embarrassment
talking about what an embarrassment I am
I don't know how many times I moved
seats I wish I did
I don't I remember moving more than once
and Johnny came to me each time not the
other way around
he sits down in front of me at one point
and because I'm not answering him I was
looking out of the window
and he slaps my face
and
his friend
is in our proximity
and I it didn't hurt my it didn't hurt
my face it just felt embarrassed
did he do that to me in front of people
it was the first time that anything like
that had happened in front of somebody
I got up to move again and he's just
taunting me having a laugh screaming and
then just straight up mean calling me
names
and it was oscillating between those
things and I get up slowly again and I
just
resolve to just sit the rest of the time
up at the front of the plane
and
as I get up
he kind of kicks the swivel chair into
my hip kind of just hits me
and I look at him and he asks me what
what are you gonna do about it
we I just stared at him I just stared
at him and wanted him to see me I wanted
to get through to him didn't feel there
was like I it felt like there was a
blackness in his eyes I wanted to look
at him I wanted him to see me it didn't
even feel like him
and
as I'm walking away
slowly trying not to be I was being very
deliberate about my movements
wasn't saying anything I wasn't engaging
I am walking away from him slowly and he
tells me to hurry the [ __ ] up
hurry up
and I just look at him one more time
wanting to penetrate the monster to see
the man that I love underneath that the
man I loved
and he tells me to hurry up again
and I pull my gaze away from him I walk
away from him
my back has turned to him and I feel
this
boot
in my back
it just kicked me
in the back
I fell to the floor I caught myself on
the floor and I just felt like I was
looking at the
floor of the plane for felt like a long
time
and I didn't I thought to myself I don't
know what to do
I can't believe he just did he just
kicked me
no one said anything no one did anything
it was like you could
you could hear a pin drop on that plane
you could feel the tension but no one
did anything
and I just remember feeling so
so embarrassed
I felt so embarrassed that he could kick
me to the ground in front of people
and more embarrassing I didn't know what
to do about it I got up and I just I'll
walk to the front of the plane I sat
down
and I just looked out of the window
Jerry judges security and
my friend
both kind of under their breath asked me
are you okay objection hearsay
I spent the rest of the time looking at
using the objection
and
did there come a time that you
tape recorded Mr Depp
on this plane
I want to sit here and say like I always
like
I was telling myself I needed to leave
him
but
as he got worse he demanded the oxygen
tank from the flight attendant
flight attendant excuse me
um
and he continued to drink and then
eventually
started howling like an animal
and passed out in the bathroom
with the door locked
uh and was howling and I I at some point
pushed record on my phone because
there was that five percent part of me
instruction non-responsive
it's non-responsive
explaining what led up to her tape
recording and why I mean I'll just I
mean I can ask him will that solve it
why why did you tape record him
because I knew that Johnny wouldn't
remember
what he had done I knew he would not
remember
and if calls for speculation
she could say she can say which why she
did it and what she thought but that did
that last part called her speculation I
knew
um why did you take record in my
experience when Johnny was that
inebriated
he would not remember what he had done
calls for speculation
how can that account for speculation of
sustain the objection
all right let's go to defendants 221
and I'm going to play three different
parts for it
may we approach please okay
so we're going to start with 221 and
we're going to call it a and that'll be
0 through 1 minute
I'm here
okay sure
with the first one with zero to one
minute and turn up the volume just I
mean there's part of it that the noise
of the airplane is a little bit
loud but
to be able to pick up the noise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no
and then the second one is from 250 to
320. 30 seconds
[Music]
hello
[Music]
yourself
221 is in evidence all of 221 is already
in evidence so may I play the third one
then and then we can take the break yes
thank you that would be it you can play
all of it if you'd like
that's why I think I think they'll
torture the jury I do that your honor uh
9 30 to 10 just 30 seconds more
[Music]
[Music]
all right and you can be changing gears
after that or do you have more questions
for this issue no I think this would be
okay all right let's go and take our
morning break then just to not do any
outside research and don't discuss the
case with anybody
foreign
thank you and again ma'am since you're
still testifying don't discuss your
testimony with anybody at this point
okay
all right so let's just come back at
let's make it a 11 42. all right thank
you
okay sure
all right we ready for the jury then yes
you're okay thank you
thank you
all right thank you all right see your
next question
thank you
Amber following the plane ride what did
you do once you arrived once you landed
in LA
I uh called
I called for a cab
car to pick me up met me at the private
airport and I left uh I got straight off
the plane as soon as we
touched down Johnny had been saying some
what he would do to me once we got on
the ground and I didn't know how long
this cycle would last so I wanted to
just get out of there and I
went to a hotel
and called my friends to join me which
was my coping strategy at the time
okay
I'm going to ask you to take a look at
defendants 204
did you reach out to objection in your
honor hearsay and bleeding
your honor I would direct your owner's
attention to the first one in blue
and the third one in blue and I would
say present sense impression and
the state state of mind at that time all
right if you want to approach yes
all right let's go to 205
defendants 205
and this is a communication between you
and Rocky Pennington your best friend is
that correct that's correct objection
hearsay
foreign
and hearsay if you want to
uh did you what if any communication did
you have with your mother or your father
following this incident objection
hearsay
sustain that
um
well let's go to let's go to defendants
222 and
you're gonna I suspect we're going to be
back up
thank you
foreign
what if any uh Communications did you
have with Kate James following the
Boston plane incident objection hearsay
I wonder if we go to 224 okay
224 my argument would be business
records exception all right you want to
come
before we do it
thank you
so
what if anything did you do the evening
of the 24th of May
I reached out to friends and family
asked for support objection hearsay it's
a stage
and surrounded myself with them
with that
what if anything did you do for Lily
Rose's birthday
I
that's why we had gone back to LA Johnny
was sick
um
after having passed out on the plane so
I took her to dinner
um we went to Benihana's
um
uh it was
you know again put on my smile took her
out
tried to
make her feel loved and celebrated for
her birthday and
uh then I booked a flight out to New
York to go back to New York
um obviously without Johnny
I'm going to ask you
ask you to turn to 225
and you're going to be
referring to the last two blue spots on
that page
um
with the state of mind
um
thank you
mental condition
right it doesn't it's still here say
your honor
may we approach you
I'm going to ask you to turn now to 228
your honor we're going to object on
hearsay first first line your honor okay
is all I'm I under I understand in your
owner's ruling but I think
all right you've got to come forward
that's fine
so
tell us uh what to please tell the jury
what you did then over that night the
next day and
and
at the hotel
I cried a lot
tried to surround myself with my friends
and resolve to
leave him
I felt
I felt
powerless
nothing I did
made a difference you know on the plane
I was so careful objection I'm
responsive
please just tell us what you did and you
can tell how you feel but don't go
backwards okay
I um
resolved
tried to
get the strength to commit to leaving
him I knew I had to
I knew nothing else would make a
difference so I
got myself back to LA I mean I'm Excuse
me New York
and uh started going to Al-Anon meetings
every day
to support it's a support group for
people who love addicts and alcoholics
what if any Communications did you have
with Steven deuter's objection hearsay
all right
what
let me ask it this way what if any
Communications did you have with Mr
deuter's communicating on behalf of Mr
Depp objection hearsay Agency on that
you're all you have to lay a foundation
for that all right let's go to 229a
foreign
could you without saying what the
content is can you tell us who this text
message is with
Johnny's assistance
what's his name his name is Steven
deuter's okay
okay and what if any
communication were you having with him
following the Boston plane incident
objection hearsay may we approach all
right
foreign
okay
did you communicate at all with Mr Depp
in the days following the plain Boston
plane incident
yes I did
please tell the jury about those
Communications
I heard from him
um
directly I also heard from him through
his assistants who were texting for him
objection your honor hearsay I'll
sustain the objection you're not allowed
to testify about the text messages with
his assistant but can you tell the jury
about your Communications with Mr Depp
okay
it's kind of confusing because
he was texting through them objection
objection I'll strike that from the
record you'll just regard that testimony
please answer the question just confine
it to the communications you had with Mr
death please
uh he that he was sorry and told me that
he was in a blackout
he didn't remember everything about what
he did remember he was ashamed of
uh he begged me to forgive him he said
he understood
and forgive me forgave me if I if I
never wanted to speak to him again
I
he texted me at one point and then
and then I didn't respond right away and
he
text me again that he understood
that I had made my decision to move on
and good luck and I was better for it
and
and then continue to
um
contact me
I spoke to him when I was in New York on
the phone and he said that he was
he had a chip or that he was going to
meetings that he
I think at the time mentioned a sober
uh another celebrity that was kind of
advising him
on sobriety or not advising him but you
know encouraging him and he was saying
well look you know me and this person
we're
we're doing we're even went to a meeting
um I've got three days sober four days
sober
and that was the last time
the monster will never come back monster
will never come back and because it felt
like such a different
it felt so much worse than it had ever
been before
and because I had
you know when I went to New York and I
was trying to get my strength
to leave him I actually thought that it
kind of
would be the turning point it I thought
I had effective objection your honor
non-responsive
thank you go ahead please continue
I thought I
I thought things would change
did you
draft any kind of email to Mr Depp to
express your emotions and how you felt
about all this objection hearsay
I I well let's go I'll lay the
foundation your honor let's go to
defendants 239 239
objection here say your honor and I
would say both present sense impression
and definitely State of Mind your honor
sustain the objection all right
so
did you ultimately communicate
to Mr Depp
what you first drafted up in an email
without saying anything about what's in
the email
that calls for hearsayer Honor
I'm just asking if she did
not what she said correct okay
overruled
did you communicate to Mr Deb what you
had drafted in the email and don't you
don't get to say what you said
and
what if any response did Mr Depp have
to your sending that email to him
he
he came to New York
two fight for the relationship for me
to prove that he was sober and he was
committed to changing
I believed he was
embarrassed and sorry he said he was and
I believed him
so I took him back or I'm
and come back with him
on the condition that he would
hold his promise
to do the treatment to do the full detox
clean up and never go back
so I'm gonna take you now up to the June
through August 2014 time frame and I
think you testified earlier and others
have as well that Mr Depp brought in Dr
Kipper and his group correct yes I did
could you please describe for the jury
what those next few months were like
foreign
this doctor gets brought on that had
that we had been talking about I'd heard
this name before
and all of a sudden this doctor Dr
Kipper
who apparently wrote a book on addiction
and
was this doctor was going to be the
solution The Cure you know uh
and he got he got brought on board and
all of a sudden the plan was that this
team would be involved in Johnny's
recovery
so it felt real felt serious I felt like
protected you know I had already by this
point heard a million times it seems
like a promise is to get clean and sober
but this felt like
a change
and they were going to come to Boston
and start working with Johnny and the
plan was to keep Johnny
on on the same level
of drugs that he was on since he was
filming they needed him to finish
filming the movie uh so he was going to
be maintained with his
um with prescription pills including the
painkillers
and
the the plan was he would obviously
abstain from alcohol completely and all
other drugs like weed and Coke
and then when he finished filming the
plan was to objection your honor here
say
and lack of foundation
I don't understand
what the objection I don't think it is I
think she was just explaining the
context there I don't think she was
saying the foundation how she knew but
it's fine how did you know that
I was involved in the conversations
with the doctors and with his sister
objection honor that's still hearsay all
right that part is
um so uh what did what happened next
as a result of these communications
without saying what the communications
were
a nurse came to Boston
where Johnny was I just would come for
short periods of time in between I mean
on weekends from filming until I wrapped
my movie which I did
I think in May
if I am not mistaken and then I went to
Boston and I was there and saw a nurse
was
flown out to Boston Debbie Lloyd
and I believe Kipper came out too and
they put Johnny on a bunch of new
medications which they shared with me
told me about rejection your honor
hearsay
I've been testified to what
so what happened then
I saw his medications change
um
I know the amount that Johnny told them
he was on
was so that they they could maintain him
for the filming meaning not to make a
drastic change in the amount of
painkillers he was taking
but he
his behavior his whole personality
changed
drastically
he would be speaking to me
and at the time I was staying in Boston
with him having wrapped my movie and he
would in mid midsummons mid word fall
asleep
one time I was sitting across from him
and he would come in and out of sleep
being awake or completely what appeared
to be asleep while talking to me and he
had a cigarette in his hand and you know
Johnny constantly smoked and he just sat
this cigarette you know as he fell
asleep while speaking down on his leg
they're hand-rolled cigarettes they
don't stay lit very long thankfully but
you know he it was things like that and
I didn't understand it even though I had
experience
with drug use
um
in my family I hadn't seen anything like
this and it was so dramatic the change
that I was trying to figure out with the
nurses and doctors what happened what
changed how we could explain the change
and what medications were causing it
I knew there were new medications
involved so
you know I was constantly
um worried and in communication and
Johnny's Behavior got worse and worse
more of this passing out nodding off
waking up in the middle of the night
screaming waking up in the middle of the
night sometimes crying and the emotions
would change from one to the next like
by the by the second it would the
I remember we were on a long weekend
when he was filming in Boston and we
went to this like like a resort Retreat
hotel and
you know
he was just bawling you know I broke my
heart there was just a lot of changes
and I I really didn't know
um I felt so bad for him and I thought
maybe it was just what Kipper had
introduced into the regime the
medications
but what I found out in in that time is
that he was taking about double the
amount objection your honor hearsay it
was a nice job I saw it okay it's
overruled thank you please please
continue uh it was taking about double
the amount that he told them was his
normal
when he started the the process with the
doctors so
after a few you know it's I think months
of going what is wrong and you know
turning him over when he vomited at
night or checking his pulse there were
all of a sudden I just
when I realized the amount was about
double he I realized then he had been
lying to them and me about the amounts
so that he could get extra high before
he had to detox
but that I can't just that I was so it
was such an agonizing few
that weeks months it was so agonizing I
don't know how long it lasted but I was
so concerned for this
person and he had just been
doubling up his meds because he didn't
so I Michelle can you pull up 1092
defendants exhibit 109.2
remember did you take this picture of Mr
Depp
I did your honor I'm going to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 109.2
all right objection no objection all
right 109.2 in evidence you can
publish thank you and
can you describe
what's depicted here and why you took
this picture
this was during that time when
the
prescriptions that he was on in the in
the doubling up of the opiates got so
bad that he
he was he was like this just throughout
the day off and on and then he would
take adderall and he'd be really
animated and ready to go and then it
would be
this again and it was so erotic and so
it changed so quickly and I
naively now really did not understand
what was going on
I deeply cared about
as humans well-being
and it was very confusing and scary
so did there come a time then that Mr
Depp went into detox
for roxycont
SE codines or whatever they're called
yes uh when he finished filming the plan
was to do the detox and that's what we
did and when was that
um that would have been early August of
2014 I believe we left we were there for
I think a week to 10 days 8th through
the 18th
more or less and we've heard some
testimony about this but can you please
describe for the jury what took place
during this detox on the Bahama Islands
in August 2014.
it was for the first few days
okay peaceful I the the nurse
uh and then later a nurse and Doctor
were staying on a different part of the
island
um
a few minutes drive by ATV like 10 15
minute you know by one of those ATV
vehicles but we communicated via
walkie-talkie and occasionally through
texts and
um it was just it was okay at first and
then the behavior
that it just really wasn't okay uh it
was up down he'd be mad at me then he
was wanting a hug uh he cried a lot and
then he
um
you know wanted to have sex a lot like
which is just not like Johnny at all
and it was just like that it was just up
down mood and it was like I was I felt
like a constant was catering to the mood
that whatever he was going through at
the time I was just trying to adapt and
kind of roll with it and and
Provide support I was taking his blood
pressure I was on a schedule and
constant communication with the nurses
about delivering the meds giving him his
meds at a certain time
uh I was just trying to take care of him
and uh a few days in you know the I
guess the effects of the detox really
started to change and it went from this
like erratic Behavior
up and down up and down to just really
down or mad who
bursts into uh anger at me yelling at me
I crossed the tape I walked away from it
at the table I crossed the table in a
certain way and he screamed to me about
that and tried to overturn this table
luckily it was bolted down to the um to
the deck but I remember him shaking it
and screaming and at different point he
was really calm and sweet and
thanking me and then another you know he
looked like he was balancing out and we
had a conversation and he was saying he
wanted to quit like quit the detox and
he couldn't do it anymore and I was
trying to find the language to
um
encourage him you know I was trying to
remind him how much he wanted that how
much he had told me he wanted daddy how
much he I was reminding him he told me
all the time I saved his life and he
wouldn't be doing this without me
I was telling him these things and I was
at one point in our conversations I told
him about how objection your honor
hearsay
please try to continue without what you
said please
please
um
I said something to him and uh
he got so angry at me he slapped me
across the face but he did it like while
crying
so it was the weirdest thing he's crying
saying no woman had ever
embarrassed him like that no no woman
had ever made him feel like that I heard
that for the rest of the trip too just
on repeat and I
felt bad I feel bad I still feel bad
but you know I didn't want to make him
feel embarrassed that's not what I
wanted to do
I just was sitting over my head I don't
know how to detox someone you know I
don't know how to help them see that and
I shouldn't
shouldn't have been there you know I
don't know why were you there because he
asked me to
and I didn't know that that was a
phenomenally dumb idea I don't know why
anyone
no why the doctors and nurses didn't
tell me not to I didn't
I had no idea what that was gonna look
like or be like and it was hell
you know we're on an island I'm trying
to take care of him and he was
hallucinating and objection your honor
non-responsive
overruled
screaming at me
for things that I said when I didn't say
any I hadn't said anything I I would
tell him Johnny I objection your honor
hearsay
I I think in the context your honor it's
not offered to prove the truth of the
matter asserted what's it for it's just
telling the context of sustain the
objection thank you
thank you please continue and just say
what he says and what he did and what
your observations were
he was um accusing me of having
a man in the house with me
we were in a single
you know in a cabin it's basically one
room with a closet and a bathroom I mean
there's nowhere
tied really I mean there's a closet and
a bathroom and he at one point told me
that
I was hiding somebody in the house
another point he was communicating with
someone not in the room
it would yell at me and then yell at
someone else it wasn't there
and I tried to
ask for what I should do I didn't know
what to do
it was terrifying and
strange
a whole week was
so after you left the Bahamas and
finished with the detox there where did
you go from there
we meaning Debbie Lloyd
uh
Dr Kipper and I and Johnny
we flew back to LA
and the the he was going back and forth
between saying he wasn't going to
continue to he was
committed it was back and forth
everything was up down erratic like
changing every second and we got to LA
and
uh Debbie and Kipper
communicate with me I won't say what
they said but
I I decided it would be
probably in everyone's best interests if
I went away to a hotel
um
Johnny uh put
me up in this room in this hotel while
he finished
the process of detox in LA and I had my
friends out with my girlfriends there to
support me as per usual
so let's Michelle can you pull up 272
please
and after you both returned to LA
did Mr Depp communicate with you
by text while you were apart while he
was finishing the detox
yes he did John I'd like to move the
admission of 272. yes through honor to
the first message
excuse me your honor to the second give
me the response right
and it just present sense of impression
but I'm understanding your honors
rulings on that
can we redact that second message
all right you're under a all right any
objection to somebody to redacted no
thank you your honor all right 272 is an
Evidence and we will publish
and Amber I'm going to show you now what
is defendants exhibit 272 and this is on
August 20
2014. it's a text message from Mr Depp
to you do you see that
yes I do okay and just so that we can
highlight here
he's calling you he says just to let you
know that I'm fine my angel I miss you
of course but this was the right thing
to do to speed up the process I love you
more than life yours Steve do you see
that
I do so what if any Expressions was Mr
Depp giving you at this point that he
was angry with you ever
having to help participate with the
detox or to be on the island or anything
along that line objection form compound
I I'll allow it but just
for trying to keep the record clear 272
has already been entered into evidence
without that reactions and there wasn't
any objection so I would wish if I could
have both sides to keep track of their
evidence it's not my job to keep keep
this thank you you're all right and I
just got a note to that effect so okay
so 272 is an evidence for that you can
clear the redaction and publish it
it's really the party's responsibility
to take care of the record not mine my
apologies on that one your honor
all right
all right and I overruled the objection
so she can answer the question thank
your honor
I'm sorry can you remind me what the
question yes I said that's fair that's
fair what if anything did Mr Depp say
about that you were torturing him on the
island and he didn't want you there
very confusing for me to hear that
because
even though he was
hallucinating and angry at me at various
moments when you would have these kind
of episodes
um
I did nothing but trying to take care of
him
um I
am not a nurse I did my best to support
him
and he thanked me
he thinks my mom you think my dad
and told me of course I saved his life
that he wouldn't be able to make this
change without me
and that this process was horrible and
hard on him and us and me
but that he was so thankful that I was
there for him
okay we can take this down now Michelle
thank you and um
I'm going to take you up to September
October of 2014.
[Music]
do you remember filming Magic Mike 2 in
that time frame
yes I do uh
and what if any connections did you have
with Mr Depp in that time frame
well I
bargained
with him about me doing the role he told
me he would um
he would call the actors it was a mostly
male cast
but I bargained with him it's actually
an honor hearsay
um
don't say what you said just say what he
said okay
um
he reluctantly kind of agreed
to me working
on this movie or taking a job he was
filming a different movie in London at
the time
I
wasn't
going to play a sexualized character
I wore no makeup or minimal makeup in
the movie
no sexy clothing
no kissing scenes
no sex scenes
so I went and did that film
in October of 2014 in Georgia
while he uh
finished his movie in London
and then at some point he came out
to pick me up in Georgia and was there
for my last like day or two of filming
I'm going to uh ask you to turn to
Michelle can you bring up 310 please
defendants 310
did you have communications with Mr Depp
about auditioning for another role in
this time frame objection your honor I'm
going to object to the exhibit let's
hearsay
I'm not sure who's in the
text Exchange
it is text exchange run or so uh but the
green is Mr Depp
and
uh with the the one I'm most focused on
is on the second page you're under the
top the green bubble on the second page
yes
all right so just that text
based on your Honor's rulings yes any
objection to that text no thank you if
we can get that redacted
and while that's being redacted Amber
let me ask you what if any
uh anything was Mr Depp saying to you in
this time frame we're talking November
2014 about you not working anymore or
not taking on any more work or
auditioning objection on our compound
they're all and leading subset overruled
out loud thank you
Johnny was angry with me for
working I I finished
my job and I needed to eventually find
another job meaning a movie
to work on and
he was furious at me for
he found
like we call them sites they're just
pieces of an audition pages
and he found something that had been
sent to me to consider auditioning for
and
he blew up at me for
um
yeah I think he's
what he said to me is that I didn't tell
him that I didn't ask him
and that because he didn't know about
that audition
that I hadn't done yet
that I had been hiding it
and
was furious at me
I um
I ended up not doing that audition I
believe well there was a few
one or two in that time that I did put
my I did audition for it and one or two
that I didn't
ask you now to take a look at what is
defend its exhibit 310
do you recognize this
email from Mr Deb
B yes it's a text yeah I'm going to move
for the admissions
please tell the jury
about this text and the context
this was Johnny's response to me
apologizing for having a an audition
okay
thank you all right now I'm gonna stay
in November of 2014.
[Music]
um and did their comfort time
that
Mr Depp told you that he understood that
you were not going to accept any more
jobs that you were going to stop working
when Johnny said this to me in
in an argument in
in in you know a bit of rage is the best
way I can describe it and kind of
alluded to me having agreed to not work
anymore
you
if you don't know me
is um
if it's preposterous
uh there's no way I would agree to that
although I did make concessions and gave
up a lot of objections hearsay
that wasn't overruled thank you please
continue
um so he reached out to other people and
to to me to that effect a theories of me
for
uh taking meetings there was one in
particular I I wanted one meeting I
wanted to take because it was a project
in development with a Sci-Fi writer
and I remember I wanted to take that
these things were just
con they were just constant and constant
fights but
in between them when things were good
between Johnny and I he would be
you know he would word it to me like I'm
trying to look out for you you know you
say that you don't want to be
objectified
you're doing it to yourself you know you
but at first it was because I dressed a
certain way or had sex scenes and then
it just got more narrow and more narrow
and more narrow what I could do without
taking without being the blame
for why the industry
Hollywood the entertainment industry was
putting me in a box
and objectifying me so it became my
fault I mean I believed it you know I I
believed it
I adopted a lot of these changes myself
not because Johnny
you know said you have to do it this way
but because of all the other things that
he said and did I eventually found
myself making decisions about my own
career about how I dressed but how I
wore my hair how I presented where my
eyes were cast when I walked into a room
and I believe those were my own
decisions
Amber did there come a time in in
November of 2014 that you engaged in
some couples counseling with Dr Cowan
and you and Mr Depp
we attempted to I
had stopped seeing my therapist at the
um in 2014
I
couldn't sustain seeing her
and be in the relationship with Johnny
and I chose Johnny
eventually
Dr Kipper introduced me to his close
friend Dr Cowan
and I met with Dr Cowan and agreed to
let them share communication about my
care my treatment both what I said to
Cowan and what I
said to Dr Kipper who had become my
physician as well
uh he also put a nurse on me that would
be my travel companion
and that travel companion would
keep tabs on me and report to Dr Kipper
who reported everything to Johnny
objection hearsay
calls for speculation I'll sustain the
objection okay
okay so tell us about the couple's
therapy in November 2014. so Dr Cowan
this man who is friends with Kipper is
treating me agreed to see Johnny and I
together
and uh I don't know how many minutes of
that went on before Johnny uh stormed
out not something off the table on his
way out and rolled a joint in the
bathroom before storming out of the
office slamming the door
all right so I'm going to take you up to
December of 2014 and specifically
December 17 2014.
um and I'm going to ask you to take a do
you what if anything do you recall of an
incident with Mr Deborah letting the
Clive
Barker
he was the Sci-Fi writer that I liked
well fantasy sci-fi writer
um
I
really I kind of had a dream Project
based on a book that I I loved of this
author
um he's just a weirdo genius genius
artist writer and I had a meeting with
him through another director about a
piece of property he wanted to make into
a a movie
and
um
I just remember uh we were I believe
we're at the ECB
it was in December of 2014 when
um
Johnny found out that I had this meeting
scheduled
and
um
furious at me
accuse me of
having this plan to sleep with this he
was mad that I was taking the meeting at
this man's house but the man was
was very ill like terminally ill and not
able to leave his his bed or his home he
was under home care and
very ill and the person who was
introducing us explained to me how we
had to meet and I did
and
that was a big problem
for Johnny at first it was
um that he
was concerned about my safety and I
thought that was
sweet and you know there there is
something that's
I thought was sweet and romantic about
that but um
combined with the drinking it just he he
it was not very long before I was being
accused of full-on having this other
plan to sleep with the writer in order
to get this part that I was already
being
you know basically offered to develop
and it was just this
you know he switched from me having he
was accusing me of having this ulterior
motive with this director the director
having it with me then with this writer
and
um in the the important thing I can try
to get across in this moment is that
nothing I said
no amount of explaining apologizing
accepting not accepting
agreeing to not go nothing worked
nothing changed
how mad he was at me and constantly
telling me I had done something wrong to
deserve what was happening until of
course
he takes it too far
hits me too hard breaks too many things
in the house and then leaves
which was the pattern and he would leave
and not have to deal with the cleanup
never had to deal with the cleanup he
never had to deal with the destruction
or see me or the house that he had
destroyed he never had to deal with my
face the next day he was just just go I
called it splitting he just split
and
eventually I get an apology of some kind
or I would get an offer to
have him come over he would offer to
come over and talk or give me my piece
or give me my goodbye
and in many ways I found myself
accepting
that knowing it was kind of false
pretense because I too wanted to resolve
it I didn't want him to think I was
sleeping with the Sci-Fi writer I didn't
want him to think that I was
this [ __ ] he he he
said I was all the time I mean part of
me really wanted to believe
that he didn't mean those things and I
wanted to get to that part of him that
would tell me he didn't mean what he
said and that he was acting this way
because he was messed up you know
and the cycle would repeat I suppose was
there any physical violence on or around
December 17 2014.
I um
yes is the answer to your question I
just don't I don't really remember
what happened in that fight
I remember
more afterwards I remember how
apologetic he was for it
I remember him telling me he took it too
far
I remember him saying he'd never do it
again
and I remember wanting to get to
Christmas you know I
Christmases or heartache probably for
everyone and I remember
it was close enough to Christmas that I
was tired
and I wanted to be in a forgiving not
forgiving I wanted to be in a kind
gentle peaceful state for Christmas I
didn't want to go through a breakup this
time I didn't want to
you know that's what I remember of that
time let's bring up defendants exhibit
321 Michelle
people and this is on 1217 2014.
just a text message exchange between you
and Mr Depp
yes it is your honor I'd like to move
the admission of defendants 321
any objection
sorry your honor just a quick minute
your honor no objection all right 321 in
evidence you can publish it please
Amber I'm just going to do what turn
your attention to this this is an email
exchange between you and Mr Depp and he
says
I am truly sorry to have upset you to
the degree that I have I couldn't be
more sorry for yet again ruining your
day
I do of course take your generosity your
selflessness your affection and your
sweet doting deeply into my heart
and I think that I've been reciprocal
Agony is never the answer to any
equation or occasion nor is Rage
please know that my apology is sincere
and solid and as stupid as it sounds I
hope you're meeting with Clive Barker is
excellent
you see that
yes okay and then you respond thank you
for your words
and you indicate you just left Betty
Sue's that's his mother
yes and
I then had a um
uh a
glass of wine with my former agent Megan
okay that um
that
afterwards
she said she encouraged
um objection hearsay yeah okay thank you
sure all right and we can take that down
let's bring up 325 defendants 325 please
and this is an email exchange the
following day 12 18 2014 is that correct
yes okay urinary moved the admission of
defendants 325
it's already in oh it's already in your
honor my apologies
we'll get that figured out at lunch with
what retractions
it's already in so it's been in evidence
does anybody over there have a list of
evidence that's already in evidence yes
okay we're making sure
ours indicates it is it's in evidence
without reduction is your honor it is
it was redacted I don't know what was
redacted to the reductions don't
is that that's how it is in evidence Mr
Murphy
we can check we'll check our copy thank
you
it's fine your honor we've confirmed yes
thank you
all right it can be published thank you
foreign
see it on your screen
all right we'll take care of that during
the break if you could just share it
there oh get it okay thank you
all right okay okay thank you so this is
from Mr dab right says it's a way I've
let it go too far went too far do you
see that yes I do I always regret it
when I jump or worse when you jump
I don't want to be conditioned to
continue that behavior therefore I'll
put in heavy work with shrink
what is your understanding of what he's
referring to with shrink
um psychology action calls for
speculation
did you have an understanding of what he
meant yes I knew exactly what he meant
and what did he mean shrank his shrink
what did he call shrink
he Johnny called shrinks meaning of
psychologists therapists shrank
okay
I'm sorry for being less for your
disappointment in me for my behavior I'm
a [ __ ] Savage you see that
yes all right gonna lose that gonna lose
that the devil is all around right
now you respond to this
and of course before you go there and he
says
I am well aware I should have been
bigger at the moment and that it will
never again manifest in negative
experiences it can be done what a killer
concept to visualize
do you see that yes I do and you respond
I love you I miss you already correct
that's right right and
what if anything is that in consistent
with
the cycle that you have described
well
the language
he used after
particularly violent
episodes
was Savage
monster devil
so we ended up both calling his
other side
the sight of Johnny that
would do and say
unbelievably horrible things
is very different from the other Johnny
that was in my opinion exact opposite
and this is typical of the apologies
that I would get
um
when he took it too far physically
I was encouraged because I thought it
meant he understood that he could really
hurt me
sometimes I didn't think he understood
how much he could hurt me
physically I mean
so
after this I
I had a invisible bruise I I don't
remember where but I remember what other
people well I can't say that what they
said so
anyway
um
and I you know
in these fights
we tried to stand up for myself by
December 2014.
I was pushing back I'd push him off of
me I'd try to hit his hands away
I tried to always get back up which
sometimes not sometimes almost always
made it worse
always seem to provoke him
um
but I tried
and worse I you know I would yell at him
I'd scream at him
I calm ugly names so ashamed of the
names we call each other it was awful
it was awful we both
got into that pattern it was so
you know I felt so angry that this was
happening to me and it felt it just felt
so
unfair you know
it felt like nothing I could do felt
like nothing I could do would change the
sobriety patterns but like nothing I
could do would stand up for him and
nothing I did made him stop hitting me
nothing
so
you know I tried for over a year maybe
maybe two
of just not responding physically not
responding verbally just staring at him
I tried to freeze I tried to
go to a different place I just I would
try then lashing out verbally I would
try to threaten that if he hit me again
that I would call the police you know
the police were called several times but
I tried to do everything I even
threatened to leave him you know and
tried to leave him and nothing was
working
and I think by this point in our
relationship
um
we're both saying awful things to each
other
it's creaming at each other and
unfortunately
um
when Johnny would start hitting me he'd
just win
I'll subscribe it
you're this might be a good okay all
right we'll go ladies and gentlemen
we'll go ahead and take our lunch break
at this time until two o'clock please do
not discuss the case or do any outside
research okay thank you
foreign
and again ma'am just don't discuss your
testimony with anybody this time okay
all right thank you so two o'clock all
right thank you
all right
thank you
okay are you ready for the jury
okay
[Music]
thank you
all right thank you all right maybe
seated your next question thank you your
honor Michelle can you bring up
defendants exhibit 236 which has already
been admitted thank you
and bro this I'm jumping back to the
Boston plane incident just for a moment
uh we had a lot of different texts and a
lot of exchange but I just wanted to
point out to you this text message is
from this is from Mr Depp to you correct
yes and this is on 5 25 the day after
the Boston plane incident
that's correct all right and he is
saying once again I find myself in a
place of Shame and regret of course I am
sorry I really don't know why or what
happened but I will never do it again I
want to get better for you and for me I
must
my illness somehow crept up and grabbed
me I can't do it again I can't live like
that again
I know you can't either
and I will for both of us starting today
I love you again I'm so sorry so sorry
I love you and feel so bad for letting
you down do you see that
I do and was that the message that he
that you testified to that he gave you
yes
all right now I'm going to jump back to
where we left off we're up in January of
2015.
um Danish girl you're filming in London
is that correct
uh yes that would have been
January 2015. okay now we heard some
testimony from Isaac Baruch earlier
about a telephone call call that you had
with Mr Depp do you recall that call
I do can you please tell the jury and
remember to tell them what Mr Depp was
saying on that call
and you can give the back I didn't mean
to cut you off on the context go ahead
um
is it okay to
that the nature of the conversation was
pleasant
um
friendly fine normal and uh then
uh Johnny stopped
making sense with this like you know
he'd start a sentence and then Trail off
and act confused when I would
I would be confused
and
um
that pattern kind of increased pretty
dramatically in a short amount of time
and I was in a hotel room in London
speaking to him in Los Angeles
and the phone what I assumed cut off
I thought it was a connection issue
and I remember getting out of bed and
walking into the bathroom to get
something and I was redialing him
and in the span of that short amount of
time we had been disconnected it was
minutes uh not even minutes
I called him back thinking the phone had
been disconnected and he answered and he
said
how could you tell me that how could you
say that to me
who who the [ __ ] is he who the [ __ ] is
he and he asked me that a few times and
I was
so confused I you know I didn't
understand what he was talking about
I expressed that to him he says who is
the guy the one in New York that you're
[ __ ]
and it was a
it was such a bizarre conversation
because it it had already started to
feel like
he
was not making it was almost as if he
was confused by what sentence he had
started by the time he got to the end of
it
and then all of a sudden he he tells me
that I have just told him
that I had
a boyfriend or a lover in New York and I
had he's accusing me of having just told
him about it
which was crazy
to me
mm-hmm
Not only was that not accurate I would
never have communicated with him like
that oh more or less called him on the
phone to do it and then call him back
and wonder
what the connection issue was it was
just the most bizarre thing
but he was
so worked up incoherent and accusing me
of having had this conversation with him
eventually the line drops out
and I spoke to the person who picked up
the phone
okay
and how did that end
um I no longer spoke to
Johnny I probably can't say what the
person told me
are we talking about Isaac Brew yes okay
so without saying what he said you had a
brief conversation with Mr Baruch and
that was the end of the call I did
um it was my understanding Johnny was
passion hearsay okay Mr sustain all
right January 25
2015 Tokyo
please tell it's the premiere of more to
Mordecai correct did you accompany Mr
Depp to Tokyo for the premiere of
Mordecai I I did
um when I was pleased to tell the jury
about that trip
well I had just uh
started to pick out the wedding dress
right before that trip
and plans were moving for us to get
married
um
shortly after this trip so we took this
trip to promote his movie I went with
him
we got in an argument in the hotel room
and I um I said I don't remember what I
said to him but I
said something snotty to to him to that
provoked him it provoked him
um and when I walked into the hallway he
grabbed me by the arm and slam me up
against the the hallway wall and I kind
of struggled with him tried to push him
off of me and I managed to get out of
his grasp
enough to take a few steps and kind of I
kind of curved around and went into the
closet
and by the time I made it into the
closet he had me by the hair and
um what felt like he was just wailing on
me but in a really sloppy way like
hitting the back of my head and kind of
wrestled me down to the floor I I mean
it felt to me like I didn't even have a
fair shot because I wasn't even really I
wasn't facing him or looking at him I
was walking away from him
um or else
you know I I would have at this point
even like had a I would have tried to
defend myself more but I I didn't I I
kind of felt like it didn't see it
coming and he just wrestled me down to
the ground and I remember
uh he was screaming at me I mean like
really screaming loud
uh
and what I remember of that is trying to
get up and him kind of wrestling me back
down and at one point put his knee on my
back
kind of like kneeling on my back
and I just had this like
struggle with him
and I look at him and he's still got his
glasses on
I just remember looking at him and
thinking that was so
he just looked like he hadn't been
through anything you know he still had
his glasses on sunglasses
and he was screaming at me that he hated
me
that it was over you want to marry me
he was disgusted he's disgusting he made
this mistake it was a big mistake and
everyone hated me
and
I remember crying
on the floor
just
more than anything I was heartbroken I
thought maybe he was serious I thought
maybe God he doesn't love me maybe this
maybe he really feels these this way I
broke my arm
broke my heart I wanted to marry him so
bad I wanted
this is something I loved you know yes
it was awful at times but I loved him
and what he did on her non-responsive
what he was saying to me hurt
just as bad as anything else
I just remember that
he left me on the on the closet floor
and
is embarrassing or
as embarrassing as it is to say I
I went up to him
at some point I don't know how much time
had passed he was um sitting at the
piano in the living room of the hotel
room that we had
it's so
I know it may be hard to understand
hard for me to hear myself say but I
felt
I just wanted it to stop I wanted things
to just be okay
and I just sat next to him on the piano
and I
just leave my head up on his shoulder
and it was of course I was mad of course
I was mad and oh it's horrible when he'd
done it
but on the other hand I just wanted us
to be okay
I
could just put this other I could put
the physical stuff in a box and
I just kept going back on
how much I love this person
so just
[Music]
put my makeup on and went to the
premiere with him and
watch a red carpet with him and and
remember in the car
checking my opponent obsessively for
pictures because my back was my dress
was backlights
of all times to have a backless dress
ing my
I was looking at pictures it was on the
red carpet
surreal because it just
checking for bruises and making sure
that nothing like there would be no
marks on me and we just looked like this
other thing on this red carpet when it
was just
it was not like that
embarrassing
you know it's hard to
I'm sure it's hard time
responsive I don't sustain the objection
next question I'm going to take you to
February the next month 2015 to your
wedding
can you please tell the jury about your
wedding
so we get married in Los Angeles
I
get a sense that
we were just it was wedding running
around Los Angeles I was
getting married that day and I remember
running around getting I went to therapy
and
you know uh got ready and Johnny and I
met at the penthouses downtown
and I
um wear a white dress and
um a veil a Bobby pinned in my hair
um
and
I walked out of that Penthouse I met up
with I met with Johnny in the hallway
and
I thought he looked so
handsome
and he seemed happy
and
I felt
we were making the right decision I was
so looking forward to
having this I thought I would get
married and we'd have stability
safety
so I um
we get in the car we get into actually
Johnny's car and
for the second time since I've known
Johnny he drove uh himself drove us in
his truck
it was weird being in the car with him
alone you know we didn't have that
um
and we drove to his mom's house
and a Justice of the Peace arrived
looking kind of surprised
and she married Us in the living room of
his mother's house Betty Sue
with our families together
around my best friend my mom
his mom we eat food
with the kids they were there
and we had a wonderful evening and then
got up and got on
the plane either the next morning or the
day after
and flew to Johnny's Island and we had
the what we had planned for the better
you know we had planned for the better
part of a year or so
maybe eight months uh for this uh three
day wedding on his Island uh with our
close friends about 12 people maybe 15
people
and we had these little houses built
like 10 not tents but not houses these
little the guests we had them built and
designed on the island and
we had people come out and it was magic
you know you
I was marrying
the love of my life
it was complicated
but um
I thought
it was the love of my life
and we had our friends and family out
and we had this three-day
event the first of which the first night
of which was supposed to be he and I
separate with our relative parties of me
with the bridal party and him with
his fellas the bridal party we had
planned to do a cuddle puddle
uh have mushrooms and drink wine and you
know have our own like you know girl
party separate and then we the next day
have the wedding festivities
we're going to be married around Sunset
and
um on this Beach uh not the beach that
Johnny had
a name for me although we I think we
originally planned on having the
ceremony on that beach but it was
changed at some point
to the other Beach and we
walked down the aisle well the beach
aisle and
um said our vowels and the sunset behind
us and we took pictures with our family
and
we shot the bird meaning the middle
finger up at the paparazzi helicopter
circling or plane circling around us
while we were on the altar
and we danced and celebrated
and then I left the island because I had
to go work
when you say you left the island you had
to go to work what what were you working
on that required that I was filming the
Danish girl in London which is the film
that I had been in London for in January
when Johnny was hallucinating on on the
phone with me I was there doing kind of
prep work for that film
Deb going to at that point
well the plan why we did the wedding
when we
did it is because he had always had this
commitment to do uh Pirates five
and he was going to shoot that in
Australia and I was going to shoot the
Danish girl and I started the Danish
girl
um in early February and he was going to
fly out mid February to Australia so his
movie was going to take the majority of
the Year meaning until August
so
um maybe longer so that the plan was to
do it when we did it so that we didn't
have to wait until the fall of the
following year so
shortly after I left Johnny return to
Los Angeles and then flew from Los
Angeles on to
um
Australia to shoot P5 a pirate's five
excuse me okay and what was the plan uh
for you when you finished with uh Danish
girl
the plan was always for me to wrap on my
movie and then come and join him in
Australia where he was filming P5
Pirates five okay and when approximately
was that
that was March
third
March 3rd that you wrapped that you
finished with Danish girl
I believe
I can't read call the exact date but I
believe it was around that time yes okay
and then
tell the jury where did you fly to to
get to Australia how long of a
turnaround was it for you to get to
Australia
it was about 24 hour
I think it's about 24 hours I could be
mistaken on the exact amount of time but
I remember it's quite a distance from
London I was filming in London he was
filming in Australia
effectively you have to fly 12 hours
stop get on a different plane and fly I
think around the same amount of time if
I'm not mistaken okay
so when you arrived before you finished
wrapping with Danish girl and were
heading out shortly before what if any
Communications did you and Mr Depp have
well at first it was
it was great even though we were
separate it was so hard to it was so
hard to um
uh leave the you know leave right after
you get married
especially considering that
um in Johnny and I's relationship it was
always so much worse when I went away to
work
it just that's when problems started so
I was hard but we communicated pretty
consistently and it was positive until
it it started to change and it
I got the sense that he thought I was
sleeping with the director and then it
was with the the actor I was filming
with
who was the actor you were filming with
uh Eddie Redmayne okay
uh
of course I'm not of course I was not
not that it mattered but
um you know I could do my best to feel
the accusations and then they would kind
of subside and I thought things were
okay
and one day right before I'm supposed to
fly to Australia he uh like write the I
think it was the night before I was
supposed to leave to go to Australia he
calls my uh hotel room apparently
I had a sense that the phone was ringing
um I think it was in the shower at the
time but not much time had passed and I
get a knock on the door and it was
someone from the hotel that I was
staying at the hotel staff had been sent
up to the room because John calls for
hearsay and speculation I was sustain
the objection so don't tell what the
staff said what happened next
uh then I start communicating with
Johnny
I started I mean were you was he on the
phone did you call him what what
happened here he called the room and
then my cell phone and then once I was
on the cell phone he was accusing me of
not being in my room so he called the
room and I had to prove that I was in
the room because
by answering the phone
and we had a lengthy uh kind of circular
conversation about where I was and why I
didn't answer the phone
uh why didn't answer the phone
immediately uh he didn't sound like he
was connected to reality it just didn't
seem like
to me it it seemed like a previous
pattern
I I was unsure what to make of it
because he wasn't right in front of me
but he was accusing me of uh what it
seemed like is uh having I guess an
affair or a reason to not be in the room
that I got a sense from him was
um
you know cheating or on you know that I
was hiding something and I was why I
wasn't answering the phone and hence why
um I got the knock on the door
that was right before I left so as your
head you before you headed to Australia
what if
what if you make of Mr Depp for him to
get you MDMA
um that's ridiculous why is that
ridiculous
because
um I would never since that time I
learned my lesson the hard way on the
plane to Russia I would never
do MDMA with him
that's I I'm asking for a problem in
that case like that I would never do
that okay
okay so you flew to Australia
and met with Mr debb Right and I'm going
to uh can we pull up defendants 1809 and
your honor these are some of the
pictures that Mr King you may recall was
testifying earlier said he had on his
phone and then those were given so um
so I don't have these is what you're
saying okay that's fine
1809
I'm just going to show you a few
pictures
Amber do you recognize
and I realized you didn't take this
photo I'm going to move the admission of
it though your honor any objection 1809
yeah thank you all right 1809 in
evidence
and love me
pass one up and give one to the other
side we tried to
given this strangeness of this
may I approach your arm yes
thank you
I appreciate it
would you recognize this photo
I do and could you tell the jury what
this is
that is the driveway leading up to the
house that Johnny was renting while
shooting Pirates five
then I'm going into
I'm going to make this try to make this
a little faster and I'm going to go
18 or 10
I'm going to miss if you have a series
of photos if you want to show Council
what they are maybe we can get them in
it all together and then you could just
yes go on with your questions yes
in fact
and these are all I will represent ones
that we got from Mr King all right if
you want to take a look at them if I may
just approach I'll give you the whole
step okay that's fine
thank you
but by the way Amber do you see those
kangaroos in there
when I was pulling up to the house I saw
kangaroos
as well
this was a pretty big driveway
it was a pretty ice objection sorry no
no objection to any of them I don't
believe so you're on but make sure you
look through them all too I just want to
make sure go ahead and read them into
the record once you have looked through
them all and then
foreign
thank your honor I've reviewed them I
have no objection to any of these
photographs so we'll enter into evidence
defendants 1804 1805.
1806
1807 1808.
1810
1811 1812.
1814.
1815
1816 18 17 18 19 18 20 18 21
1825
1827
1828
1829
1830
1831
1834
1835
1837
1838
1839
1840 1841 and 1842 did I get them all
evidence okay they're all in evidence so
as long as you're just going to be
referencing those photos we'll keep it
on thank you your honor appreciate it
okay
whose home was this in Australia
it was a um I think like a a well-known
um Sports
Sportsman I'm racing cars or something
of that nature okay
let's say so if you can pull up 1810
is this another picture from that home
yes that looks like it's the view from
the bathroom Okay and then let's go
Michelle if you can pull up 18 11.
is that a picture of the home that's the
house yes okay
and let's go to 1812.
and that's that's the view from the
living room it opened into a lagoon
let's look at 1813.
I guess that's just another view
little over of the swimming pool correct
yes okay and then let's do one more
1814.
this is inside the house yes
okay
um and if you can look to the back here
where I've got my I'm making some what
if anything is that back there that's
the kitchen okay this is the dining room
and this is on the main level what we're
looking at is the the dining room table
on the main level with the kitchen in
the background
thank you
now I'm going to ask you to take this
jury through
your experience what happened in
Australia once you arrived there
well I am
I was nervous because of the
conversations that I had with him before
I left
and then
in in transit I stopped in Dubai and
spoke to him too
so I was a little nervous
but he indicated me that he wanted me to
come he did
said I I miss my wife at the end of the
phone call that we had in the um in the
airport I called him from Dubai
and
um
he he said I miss my wife I miss my wife
I felt okay safe to you know and I
missed him so much you know I that's all
I want all I wanted to do is
see my new husband I
um I flew in I arrived early I
immediately I walked into the bedroom I
was so excited to to see him
and he was
so like he had lost a ton of weight
so
I just knew something was up
um and
he kind of quickly you know uh
kiss me and kind of we had some
interaction it was brief he was leaving
to go work he had to work that day
but then uh after he the plan was he
would come back which he did in the
evening and then he was supposed to have
a three-day uh weekend a long weekend so
he comes back that evening and the chef
had kind of prepared some things for the
fridge mashed potatoes I think spinach
as well
um there's some steaks in the fridge but
he had kind of prepped some of the the
sides
and I was looking forward to having this
kind of you know our style at home date
you know we've just been you know we're
a new married couple we hadn't seen each
other for basically a month
after getting married and uh
I
start dinner and am happy to see him and
at some point early in that evening
he pulls out a bag of MDMA I asked him
what it was
and he told me it was MDMA
and I was surprised because at the time
that was
you know like there was no question mark
as to how I would respond to that or so
I thought it's like what do you why
would you even think that that's okay
he had already gotten clean and sober I
was
you know touch and go but for the
wedding
he was drinking Becks I think at some
point he did have wine on the island but
it wasn't it it wasn't an issue right
just moved ahead so I was surprised that
he would even pull out this bag and well
frankly not hide it from me and he kind
of seemed to suggest that we should do
it together
and I was like absolutely not
like I just got here I just got here I
want to see you I don't want to spend
time with you
I've it was the exact
opposite of what I expected and what I
wanted
um
and it just seemed delusional at the
time to me that he would even suggest
this to be something that I could
participate in with him
if you had been through what I had been
through at that point it's crazy
and at some point
um
he drinks in front of me at first I
think it was like a Malbec or a wine or
something
and I remember we hadn't like it's that
it kind of started the art an argument
and that was upstairs in that room that
we just looked uh at a picture of you
know by the sunflowers that's more or
less where we were standing just closer
to the kitchen
and we get in an argument and I shove
past him just stomp off
and he grabs me
we have an argument about
me walking away am I walking out of this
and in my head I was like I I would I
actually wasn't thinking of leaving yet
but
that would later be going through my
mind
we had a
a brief interaction and I don't
I don't remember the exact sequence of
things I wish I did
I have a lot of flashes it gets a little
bit more confusing for my ability to
recall
everything in a linear way a little
later on as things got crazier
but for this part the first night what I
distinctly remember
[Music]
is at one point I I I don't think I had
gotten very far or maybe I came back
into the room
but he when he shoved me I went flying
across these parakeet floors I mean just
skidding
across these floors
and I remember thinking it just looked
so easy for him to
throw me around like that you know I
I I just slid
screeching my skin against this like
beautiful wooden floor
we had another argument
that
was a spin-off from that it was just
kind of this on off on off sort of thing
that I remember eventually
in this
interaction
he shoves me up against the fridge
he asked me by the throat
and he just was holding me there
by my throat
and I wondered if the if it was the
drugs I wondered if it was him
it hadn't in my recollection hadn't been
that long
he has me up against the throat
he's kind of bashing me against the
the wall next to the fridge
we're kind of moving in that area
and at some point I'm in his face
and he had he I don't know if he had let
go of my neck or loosen my grip but I
remember slapping him across the face
screaming at him
screaming at me I got my hand free when
I when he tried to grab me when I walked
off
I stormed off I slammed the door
upstairs I
don't know if it was in that instance or
if it was in a later one that I
eventually barricaded the the door
um
you know I I couldn't it wouldn't stop
him from coming in he could come in the
other doors you know there's plenty of
it's a back door there's patio
but at least I'd hear it
and my this is March 2015 by this time
I'm being Medicated by his doctor he's
giving me anti-anxiety meds
giving me
you know had already tried to give me
antidepressants they didn't work for
obvious reasons I hope
I wasn't sleeping I had insomnia I'd
wake up with panic attacks my
you know I
I needed to sleep but my ability to do
so was really really compromised at this
point and I
kept thinking that um
I just wanted to hear him or know if he
came in so I could be aware so I could
be ready for what was going to come in
with him
and at some point I go back down
stairs I don't really know at what point
I gave up and stayed behind my
barricaded door but I managed to go to
sleep I took some sleeping pills
I woke up
and when I came downstairs he was still
up
uh he told he confirmed that when I
asked him that he had not slept
he had not eaten so I tried to get him
to eat
um
we get in an argument
he was accusing me of Eddie Redmayne
and uh at by this point he thought I was
working with Billy Bob Thornton on the
movie I just shot but I had already
worked with him a year earlier but he
was very upset about
him and the gentleman that invited me to
a concert in in London you know the my
co-star he was upset about these people
even though I had done that movie a year
prior who was that uh it was Billy Bob
Thornton Jim Sturgis and Eddie Redmayne
that he was upset about and let me just
stop you for a moment have you seen Mr
Depp take any drugs by this point
oh yeah I sorry if I left that out um
that when we had the argument about the
MDMA
uh he suggested to me that it wasn't on
the no-fly list like it it wasn't on the
no list that was his argument that was
his defense like this isn't then
you didn't say I couldn't have this and
I'm you know over and over again Johnny
told me I wasn't the reason he was
getting sober but I was the reason he's
staying sober I had saved his life and
all this stuff I wasn't like it was my
it wasn't my job to police him but I
kind of ended up being in that situation
it seemed like in his mind you know when
he would express that to me so
he took the um a handful of pills and I
didn't count how many but
uh when I came back downstairs I did the
math on the amount that was left and I
think it was either eight or ten I can't
recall as I sit here now either eight or
ten pills of MDMA that he had taken or
that were left
um
I don't I remember we had a conversation
about the amount that he took
so I remember saying
here say
okay I'll sustain the objection
um
there were only a few left in the in the
bag so I think it was what he took
and I I said Johnny that or objection
here say
uh he confirmed that he took that amount
and that he could take that amount and
what amount
uh at this point there were he had taken
ten eight or ten I can't recall and when
you say at this point is that the first
night is that the second day this is the
second day this is after I've already
fallen asleep for the night in the room
upstairs come back downstairs he was
still awake
please continue with that second day
um
he's accusing me
of being mean to his sister
he was accusing me of not liking his
sister
something about the wedding I I I was
trying to
put out that fire as you will I was
trying to say no no no first of all I'm
not filming with Billy Bob no I wasn't
filming filming with Jim Sturgis yes I
filmed with Eddie Redmayne but he was
lovely gentlemen
hearsay that's not offered to prove the
truth of the matter overruled
um and then when it came up with his
sister he
um
it was accusing me of of kind of having
this animosity with uh Christy I I tried
to defend myself explaining
why her and I had
kind of become cold to one another I
don't know how else to describe it
because we never had any sort of direct
interaction that was negative we never
had any sort of Confrontation or
anything but I did my best to explain to
him
um well what I
could answer to that accusation and at
one point he um
uh oh I mentioned that well I can't say
what I mentioned he in as a result of
that phone call picks up the phone and
calls his agent
I don't know why still to this day
um he calls a few people I don't know
who's on the other line I just heard his
side of it and he's screaming at them I
got a sense that it was money that he
felt people had been stealing money from
him and that the studio had been ripping
him off
and that
um he was calling himself like a [ __ ]
or he had been hoard out
he seemed like he was upset but I did
not at this point this is the maybe
early evening it was before the sun went
down on the second day
I remember he took the phone at one
point and called my
um divorce attorney I had at some point
prior to this got a divorce attorney or
not a divorce attorney a domestic
relations attorney to do a postnup
because we got married in February and
there wasn't
there was never any mention or or talk
from Johnny about a prenup but I had had
interactions with his sister and so I
thought okay I'll get a lawyer and Let's
do let's do a post nump when Johnny
found out about that or when I reminded
him of that in Australia he went outside
and called my divorce attorney and fired
her
and said the only way out of this was
death
again and I heard that already at this
point March 2015
probably 25 times
so he's screaming at her he calls his
agents I I hear
him talking incoherently to screaming
incoherently at
my lawyer and his agent he comes back
inside and I genuinely didn't know if he
was still mad at me or if it was about
me at all I didn't know it didn't seem
like it was connected to to reality at
all
um
at some point shortly after that I have
been saying to Johnny you need to sleep
let's eat some dinner baby let's relax
please like calm down in my in my head I
was thinking that it would genuinely
change if he just got some sleep he
needed to sleep it off he needed to come
down off the drugs clearly the
combination of what he had taken pill
wise with whatever else he was hiding
from me was not good I had recognized
that sort of delusion I'd recognize that
sort of unattached to reality rage I had
recognized the patterns of those kind of
Loops where he's yelling about things
that
aren't even being discussed or talked
about I knew already that he just needed
to sleep it off
clean up you know sober up
and I thought we could I put I remember
I went to the fridge I got out the stake
so that they would
you know be ready to cook and I got out
some of the food I was gonna put
together for dinner I went upstairs
um
I don't know if I came back down in my
nightgown at that point or if that was
shortly after but
the next thing I remember
is
coming downstairs and looking for him we
had a an interaction that I can't really
describe it didn't make a lot of sense
to me
he was just belligerent
belligerent throwing things screaming at
me
and I realized I was back on the
chopping block I realized it was back
like I realized that the arrows were
appointed at me again
and I tried to defend myself I was
explaining you know trying to say that
protection honor hearsay it was not for
the prove the truth of the matter she
hasn't even said it yet but but try try
not to say what you're saying unless it
needs it for context or something
try try to say what he's sustained the
objection okay
uh
it was just belligerent I don't know how
to describe to you because it wasn't
making sense
it wasn't making sense
um I
I
I
don't know how
um
I don't know how the immediate next like
string of of
the next part of the violence actually
even initiated but
again he has me up against the wall and
I remember this time he slams me up
against the wall hard I mean I hit my
head hard
and this is a wall next to the
I say kitchenette but it's more of a bar
I remember there were these cooling
fridges and I remember kind of
being slammed up against those I
remember pushing him off of me
I remember the name calling the horror
the [ __ ] the fat ass
I remember a lot of name-calling
um
I said
um
he had he been drinking by this time
he was drinking for speculation and
leading
us leading
what if any drinks had you observed Mr
debt have by this time
well I had already seen him drink right
in front of me took a big Swig out of a
wine bottle up upstairs right in front
of me as a
um in a gesture of like looked right at
me and took a big Swig out of it as a
you know like a
a show for like you know did it right in
my face to make a point and then when I
came downstairs he was drinking from the
bottle
um
I don't I I don't know what kind of
liquor I remember there was another
bottle open and I was wondering why he
was drinking both
um but
at some point
um
uh he had me up against this the wall
next to the cooling fridges and I
remember slamming my head up against the
thing he had me by the neck
squeezing my neck and uh it got really
it got really nasty it went from like oh
no one likes you no one likes me
everyone warned me about you that's what
it was he started to tell me that
everyone
had warned him about me and that he was
she had never
married me movies he had never met me
um
no one like me you know it sounds uh
childish but
uh I I remember feeling really hurt and
then at some point I shove him hard to
get him off me and he shoved me back and
he said you want to go little girl
did that um
I couldn't as I sit here today tell you
if that happened before he choked me up
against the wall but at some point
um
I am in a in a like a struggle with him
where I'm holding his shirt lapel
and he kind of just flings me for lack
of a better way to describe it
throws me
across the room I land on the games
table it's like a ping pong table
and I don't know if I was holding on to
him or if he
pursued me separate but he gets on top
of me on the
games table
and it's just whacking me in the face
like repetitive
we struggle on the games table I don't
know
I don't know how we get up I don't know
if he pulls me up I wish I could tell
you but we were in this struggle down in
this this game's room by the bar
and um
and we had this conversation about the
the drinking or argument about the
drinking and
he holds up this bottle
to me
um
and
you know I'm I'm saying did you drink
this whole thing
something stupid uh focusing on this
detail and he
is telling me that I can't control him
anymore and
um that if I really you know if I really
wanted to try take it and then he's like
taunting me to take the bottle from him
uh if I really if I really want him to
stop why don't I why don't I take it
from him go on go on kept saying go on
and kind of gesturing with the the
bottle towards me
and uh like team does that two or three
times I reach for it he'd revoke it kind
of laugh at me
and he's holding out the bottle I think
like maybe the third time or so I get a
hold of it
I'd pick it up and I slam it down on the
ground right in between us
there's a tile floor a white tile floor
and I smashed the bottle on the floor
and that really set him off
so stupid
um
sorry he's
um it was like a light bulb switch went
off
I started screaming
um
I don't know if he backhanded me or hit
me normally I don't I don't really
recall but I remember it sent me down to
the ground
I Remember by the time I picked myself
off the floor I stand up
he's got a bottle on his hand
and he threw it at me
it missed thankfully but I kind of
pulled myself back into the bar area
I don't know how much time passed but at
some point he had a broken bottle
up against my face neck area
by my jawline and he told me he'd carve
up my face
I don't know at what point in the
evening I couldn't tell you what
sequence
wise when that happened but it was
terrifying it wasn't the first time he
said that to me he said that to me on
the plane as well
um but this time he was holding a broken
bottle
to me
uh
I I honestly don't remember if I um
threw anything in his Direction I I
don't think I did
um I just remember
him having me by the nightgown
I remember him flailing me or throwing
me around I'm flailing
um
this is
after there were some bottles broken on
the floor I think this is actually after
again
forgive me I wish I could remember the
sequence but it splashes
he's throwing these bottles at me
um I remember retreating there were also
cans like soda cans beer or soda cans
and they're coming at me one after the
other and I keep pulling myself into the
bar area there's a bar behind me in
like a I don't know like an L shape
though he's standing the only way you
can exit so I'm kind of Trapped in front
of the sink
surrounded by bar on three sides with
him in front of me ish kind of front off
to this off to the left and he's
throwing these bottles one after the
other and
I can feel glass breaking behind me
I remember feeling
um one of them go by my head really fast
I mean the velocity a real velocity
I remember being terrified
I remember I couldn't move I couldn't go
anywhere
um
I eventually I'm trying to I don't know
if you ran out of things to throw I
think that's how I move myself towards
the exit
and I believe that's most likely when we
got
kind of in this struggle by the bar area
um
because I I remember my feet slipping on
the tile as he was slamming me from
the wall
to the countertops
one point he has me up against the the
wall and he's punching the wall
he had my you know nightgown and it kind
of ripped it off my chest
I remember at one point he's teasing me
taunting me that I he has my
um my breasts and his hands
um my nightgown came completely off it
was ripped off of me
so I was naked
and I'm slipping around on this tile
and trying to get my footing and I
remember slipping on this tile glasses
underneath me and I remember just trying
to get my footing you know I felt really
destabilized and felt really vulnerable
I'm naked
and he's flinging me around and at some
point
I'm up against the wall and he's
screaming at me that he [ __ ] hates me
that it ruined his life
remember the I ruined his life over and
over
and he starts punching the the wall next
to my head
holding me by the neck I get free from
him I kind of step back
from him and it's like his energy
shifted to the phone there's a wall
mounted phone on the on the wall next to
where my head was and he went from
punching the the wall
to like realizing there was a phone
there and he picked up the phone and
he's screaming he's like at the top of
his lungs screaming I [ __ ] hate you I
[ __ ] hate you you ruined my [ __ ]
life and screaming at the top of his
lungs picks up the phone and starts
bashing the phone against the wall
against the wall where I was just being
held and I remember kind of having some
distance on on what was happening and
watching him do this and it was like his
energy had shifted and I was that phone
all of a sudden
and he was just over and over again
smashing this phone into the wall over
and over again screaming at me and I was
watching the phone every single time he
pulled his handbag it was just breaking
into
pieces that I
I remember thinking this phone is
disappearing he's smashing it to
Smithereens just going into the wall
and
at some point
he's on top of of
up
no phone but screaming the same thing I
[ __ ] hate you you ruined my [ __ ]
life
I'm on the countertop
it had me by the neck
and he felt like he was on top of me and
I'm I'm looking at it in his eyes
and I don't see him anymore
I don't see him anymore it wasn't him it
was black
I've never been
so scared of my life it was but it was
black I couldn't see him
and he was
looking at me and I was trying to get
through to him I was trying to say to
him in some way
that it was me
I was trying to get through to Johnny
and I couldn't see him I couldn't see
him at all
and
my head was bashing against the back of
the bar and I couldn't breathe
and I remember trying to get up and I
was slipping on the glass my feet were
slipping my arms were slipping on the
countertops and I remember just trying
to get up so I could breathe so I could
tell him that he was really hurting me I
didn't think he knew what he was doing
I don't know how
sorry
I'm sorry
I couldn't breathe
tonight I don't know
I don't want to do this
I couldn't
I couldn't breathe I couldn't get
through to him I couldn't
I couldn't get up but I couldn't get up
and I don't know how that ended I don't
know
I don't know how
I don't know what happened next
[Laughter]
the next thing I remember
I always been over
um backwards
on the bar meaning my chest was up
I was staring at the blue light and
my chest went on this
my back is on the countertops
and I thought he was punching me hey
buddy
he was
it is
felt this pressure I felt this pressure
he oh my pubic bonus
he was pretty
I just saw his arm I could feel his arm
moving and I it looked like he was
punching me
but I could just feel this pressure
it was like
it didn't feel pain it was just a
pressure on my
pubic bone and
yeah
I don't know
I
I
don't
remember
what I said
I just remember being really still
not wanting to move
I remember looking around the room
I remember
looking at all the broken bottles
broken glass
and I remember her that it's just not
wanting to move
because I didn't know if it was broken I
didn't know if the bottle
yeah
that he had inside me was broken I
couldn't feel it I couldn't feel it I
didn't feel pain
I didn't feel pain I didn't feel
anything I just
I didn't want it
I didn't I looked around and I saw so
much broken glass
that I didn't know
if you would know
if he would know
um
I didn't know if he would know
if it was broken or not and I just
remember
thank you please God please thank you
I hope it's still broken
I don't know how that ended
I don't know how
I got off the countertop
I
just remember it being in the bathroom
[Music]
I
remember
wretching
I don't remember the sound my voice was
making
I remember I lost control of my bladder
I remember just
wretching
I remember there was blood on the floor
um
I got up
at some point
I
don't know how that night ended
I don't remember
what happened I don't remember
I have a memory of him begging me not to
leave
I remember
going outside the front door
I remember him coming out to the front
area but I I don't remember
if that was before or after this I I
don't remember I just have that memory
I remember
uh taking a bunch of sleeping pills not
a bunch like
too
which is a lot for me
I remember falling asleep or
I don't remember falling asleep but I
know I fell asleep because I woke up the
next day
um I assume it was late morning
um he I could hear him downstairs
uh they could hear Marilyn Manson
um music not in person I could hear the
music maybe he said it was Maryland or
maybe I could recognize I don't remember
but I became aware that's what I was
hearing it was blaring
it became clear
obvious to me when I walked downstairs
he was still up he hadn't gone to sleep
again
I walked downstairs and I saw this um
Brown
on the walls going down the stairs
and the brown on the walls became clear
like it became clearer like lettering
and then it was obvious it was dried
blood
handwritten
down those that we hit a spiral
staircase like white cream walls
there's blood on the carpet
I could see blood drips
uh I I thought it was from my arms or
feet but it was drips
so
that plus the walls writing I saw this
brown letters on the wall and then
realized
that he was trying that that was a meant
to be a message but it was incoherent
I saw what looked like my name
um but I really couldn't make out most
of the rest of the message walking down
the stairs
I saw a bird in the house
surreal
I went down to the main level where my
painting Studio was and I had some
canvases out it was in the living room
area
and oh by the time I got down to the
bottom of the stairs um the the dried
blood had been kind of taken over by a
paint it was um blue navy blue paint and
then brown paint
and then it was you know on the walls on
the Lampshades
pillow pillowcases or the of the sofa
the sofa cushions there was blood in the
painting Studio the paint my canvases
have been covered with what looked like
just brown blue green red mess it was
just a mess there was a painting that
had
uh
you know a painting that the owners had
that had um
you know like a giant penis on it and
you know some other
things was a table overturned a bunch of
broken glass on that on that
floor I walked downstairs where I heard
the music coming from
and that's where I found him blurring
this music he was in the study which is
in the
by the bar
games table area off to the side and it
was just glass and blood and
broken windows and a broken window and
it just
it looked like a mess the table has
collapsed and I walked into the study
um
I'm saying a couple unbroken empty
bottles I remember wondering where they
came from
uh
and he just looked wasn't there anymore
it wasn't there
it wasn't Johnny
who's standing at the office to ask he
had his hand wrapped in this uh like
Rags or you know bandana rags
and
I I think he took them down or somehow
showed me and he said look what you made
me do I did this for you something to
that effect
and
I kind of
put together it was covered in paint
and I put together that that's
like he was using his finger
I quickly became aware that that's what
he was using as a paintbrush even though
there was lots of paint brushes around
um and
we didn't have any sort of like coherent
conversation as you can imagine
um I figured out he was missing a finger
he kind of held it up and I said what
did you do when like what what did you
do when and I realized in my head that
there had been many hours
since this probably happened assuming
that that was the happen with the phone
and in any case I I knew it had been way
too long that he had had this
blood you know that he was bleeding and
I said I'm gonna call 9-1-1 if you don't
call Jerry now
uh I don't I still don't recall which of
us
um called Jerry judge his security
um
at some point we went upstairs I I he
came upstairs but he went up to the
third floor while I was in the main
floor the the entry level floor
I went to make him a cup of coffee
because he was demanding more Red Bull
and I was thinking that's probably not a
good idea I don't know why coffee would
be so much better but in my head it was
uh
I thought maybe I don't know it's so
warm up or I I don't know their help was
coming though and I remember I made him
coffee as soon as I handed it to him he
threw it at the TV and started screaming
again it was like back to
back to square one
shortly after that security arrives
um
I I don't know how long maybe a few
seconds or minutes went by not not long
but they kind of
buying Johnny or Johnny finds them
walking out of the front door
and they were trying to figure out what
was going on and as they were kind of
looking at him and I and trying to
figure out what the heck was going on
Johnny took his
um penis out of his pants and started P
trying to pee or peeing outside of the
house
saying that he had more messages for me
and this is in front of security
and they kind of just like looked at
each other and looked at him and kind of
not laughed but kind of half
you know played it off and corralled him
it was how it looked it looked like
crowning a wild animal
back into the house with you know
with his penis still out of his pants
peeing or trying to pee that's what he
was indicating and he went to the wall
of the house and
I remember him standing at the wall
trying to leave me more saying he was
good he had more information for me he
was gonna leave me more message more
messages more more information for me it
made no sense
and um
Jerry judge his security and one of the
nurses uh shortly after I think they put
me in the theater room but shortly after
I remember talking to one of the nurses
and she was trying to give me drugs to
sedation your honor hearsay
trying to give her drugs she didn't say
anything thank you keep going
um and
I just remember
I just remember crying and rejecting
what they were trying to give me
and fighting with them about how much
they were trying to give me I I felt
like I needed
to figure out what the what what was
happening with my life
what was happening with Johnny I didn't
know if he was okay I I didn't know
I actually
had no idea like could this be something
he
could die from if anything just the
drugs and the alcohol
I mean
that alone I I didn't you know I was I
was I I just remember being scared and
being in this theater room this dark
theater room and not knowing what the
heck was going on
uh and uh I eventually was taken up to
my room by uh one of the nurses
and they I I I'm sorry Debbie
and
or or suggesting I go up to my room I
went up to my room and
I I took a quarter of what she was
trying to get me to take
and
I eventually fell asleep
I came back downstairs
um
to look for my phone which Johnny had
picked up before security came in he
picked up my phone
and said we're gonna get to the bottom
of this he wasn't making any sense at
the time I understandably just a
different nothing made sense but he
picked up my phone and was saying we're
going to get to the we're gonna I'm
gonna prove this we're gonna get to this
we're going to get to the proof of this
something to that effect I don't
remember his exact words
um and he pushed for court on my phone I
didn't actually at the time
think that he had done that I
I I had no idea but I did know that I
didn't have my phone when I woke up and
went downstairs to get it
it was dead it was sitting out on the
um dining room table by where Jerry
judge was sitting
Jerry George was on the phone and talked
to me and I went back up to bed
took more of this sedative and fell
asleep
um and then I think the next day uh
went to the closet and took out the
clothes that he hadn't painted on I
guess when he went back upstairs he had
um
like I looked like what he had done is
dip his hand in a bucket of paint and
just wiped it on my clothes just went
and he picked up another portion of my
clothes and put him in the bathtub and I
don't know if he added paint or if he
just touched was had touched them with
paint but it was this ugly navy blue
brown paint
um I packed what was packable well
hadn't been destroyed and
um
and and eventually left Australia with
uh with Ben King who you met
uh on the way there let me stop you
there because I want to ask you some
more questions about those three days
and then we can talk about Ben King and
going home
so
do you recall what bottle Mr Depp was
drinking from and then had that back and
forth with you and you threw on the
ground
objection your honor compound leading
sustained do you recall what the bottle
was no I don't
do you recall whether it was wine or
liquor
it was liquor
the wine was upstairs okay do you recall
excuse me
what color excuse me it was
um
I believe it was
um white I mean clear but I can't be
certain I think it was clear do you
remember whether it had a handle on it
or not no it was a normal bottle
I couldn't like I remember because he
was holding it like this and gestured to
me to take it I I did try to reach for
the bottle it was a normal
size bed for Life me I can't remember
like what brand
um when you woke up that third morning
and came out of your room what if any
food did you see oh yeah I forgot about
that
I'm actually on our leading overruled
there was mashed potatoes smeared all
over the bedroom door on the wall in
various places but I remember opening
the door and being really confused at
first as to what it was that little like
specks of green in it I assumed to be
spinach
and
um the throughout the house there was
food rubbed
in places just countertops walls doors
as I mentioned and
later that evening I found
um
the raw meat that I had left out the
steak
all over the house or pieces of it it
was cut up
and he had ripped my nightgown into
pieces into shreds and wrapped the meat
up like wrapped the steak
pieces up with my nightgown
it was this really beautiful burgundy
silk nightgown that had this black lace
trim I ironically got it from Dr Kipper
for a wedding gift
and it was wrap I found it I continued
to find it throughout the rest of the
time that I was in the house in
Australia there's a pieces of it in the
microwave pieces of it and a produce
drawer uh in the closet drawer
uh I mean just Raw raw meat wrapped up
in this in my nightgown as well as the
smeared food on the walls
it was
bizarre
what if anything do you recall seeing on
any mirrors
oh he had written
um
he had written on the bathroom mirrors
in the bedroom and I I believe he had
there was another mirror I just don't
recall which bathroom it was in
I suppose it was the one that I went to
which is on the very bottom level
um where I was
wretching for lack of better way to
describe it
I think it was in that bathroom that he
also wrote on that mirror as well
what if anything do you read blood and
paint sorry I'm sorry what if anything
do you recall of any lampshades being
written on it well he wrote on messages
to me
um
you know things to the effect of
go-getter
you know horror sort of thing like that
that sort of language
but calling me easy calling me a [ __ ]
um
calling me and you know like just things
about ego and what a [ __ ] I was and but
it was hard to make sense of it because
it was clear he was
just out of his mind it was I mean
the he wrote on a on a on a back of a
pillow in blood
and you can tell because it dries like
in this ugly brown color he wrote on the
walls going downstairs like it took a in
fact you could see where he it looked
like he had run out of blood because the
messages became the markings became
clearly letters
and the letters kind of
became
like I could see where he had clearly
run out of blood or it wasn't bleeding
enough and went and got paint and then
it became paint and blood you could see
both you could see where he went back
with it same with the mirrors you could
I could see where the all the dried
blood was and
and then I could see a different set of
markings with paint and some other
material
so I'm going to go back to the time in
the bar and I know this is very painful
do you recall
what Mr Depp was saying to you when he
had the bottle and was pushing it
against your pubic bone
he said uh
uh that he [ __ ] kill me
[ __ ] kill you
he said it to me over and over again
he said I'll [ __ ] kill you
did you bleed from the vagina as well
I did
and did you experience any pain later
I didn't I didn't
I wasn't thinking about that
I was heartbroken
eventually I realized that I could be
hurt because I was bleeding
but
I
I convinced myself it wasn't broken and
that
that
I
that the bottle wasn't broken or else it
would be a lot worse and the
discomfort I was feeling afterwards just
paled in comparison to how
foreign
[Music]
shocked I was I'm scared I just married
this man
married him
and forgive me for asking this but I
need to just make sure the record's
clear you were penetrated up the vagina
into the pubic bone is that correct
actually honor leading assisting
what if any penetration was there in
your vagina
I'm so sorry to do this I am so sorry
Johnny I had the bottle inside of me
and was
shoving it inside of me over and over
again
any cuts on other parts of your body
my forearms were cut
my bottoms and my feet were sliced up
pretty good
do you have any other bruising or
swelling I had bruise across my jaw I
suppose from the
one of the many
times he clocked me in the face
downstairs
um
I think
I think I just didn't
make a record of an e
anything else
I'm going to ask you to turn to
let's go to uh
18
.
10
well actually
let's go to 18
15. Michelle if you can bring that up
defendants 1815 and I think these are
all in your under service they cannot be
published
um
is this the game table
yes it is okay and is this based on your
testimony is this where you were were
you on top of this table yeah that he
briefly got on top of me
um
and was pushing on my throat actually at
some point when I was on the table I had
forgotten about that and
um
this though looks like it um
is after a lot of the stuff was cleaned
up because it didn't look quite like
this
okay and it did the table collapse yes
it did obstruction on our leading
sustained what if anything happened to
the table
the table collapsed underneath me
um when Johnny
threw me into it and got on top of me or
or fell on top of me I I honestly don't
know which one
if we could look at 1816 please
defendants
do you recognize
this what's depicted in this picture
um yes
what is it
looks like uh
the bottles that were
by Johnny on the desk when I came down
that last morning and he was still up
still drinking
if we could go to defendants 1817.
the bottle shape
the bottle shape I'm sorry go ahead
I don't um I have not
you're on Earth I had a fused is there a
question
to ask a question what more do you
recall
you know sorry it took me a minute to
respond because
it's hard
um
it took me a minute to respond because I
had not remembered seeing
the bottle
that Johnny was using on me
I hadn't
I didn't have a memory of seeing it
and
this picture I wasn't aware of until
just the other day yesterday the day
before
and
[Music]
um
and I felt my stomach tighten up like I
was going to be sick when I saw it
because even though I didn't remember
seeing the bottle what I had remembered
is a pressure
like something
Square which is why I thought he was
punching me
because I feel I was feeling the square
something firm
hitting me like butting up against my
pubic bone over and over again I felt
that pressure against my bone it felt
like a flat surface
but I
when I realized it was a an object or
bottle
and not his fist which is what I thought
you know because his his arm I could see
his arm while he was holding me down
saying
he was gonna kill me but I thought he
was you know his arm looked like he was
punching me
um and I hadn't seen this bottle I
didn't
know and then this came out in bins
evidence because you didn't share it
until this date
and so I recognize it
all right now let's go to defendants
1817.
do you recognize
this
area this picture
uh yes it looks like one area of the bar
um
obviously this is sometime later because
all the liquid is dried up it's quite
slippery I was slipping all over that
tile that's how I know
uh looks like a lot of the glass has
been cleaned up almost
okay
then let's go to 1818.
actually I think I'm sorry which one
yeah that's not in evidence yeah and
that's a duplicate let's go to 1819. my
apologies okay
do you recognize this
yes I do
what is this
this is
close to where my feet were
when I was dangling off the counter
um when he had me on the countertop by
my neck
my feet were slipping
on the tile and I just remember my feet
I remember
feeling glass underneath my feet and
slipping I couldn't get up I couldn't
alleviate the pressure
on my neck she was crushing me
that's around that not around that's
next to that
the all the way at the end of the
picture is the bar where I was standing
when
he was throwing bottles at me
can we go to 1820
do you recognize what's depicted here
yes that's um to the left would be the
where the wall mounted phone was
uh right to the left of that
um to the right of that is the little
L-shaped bar that I was telling you
about where I was trapped and
you say to the left of the wall I'm
sorry is it off the picture or on the
picture so if you're looking at this
picture
imagine
up and to the left
at person hide it site height
um was a like a and I don't know if it
was antique but it kind of looked
old-fashioned like an old-fashioned
heavy what looked heavy I didn't pick up
the receiver but it looked heavy when I
was watching it break you know it looked
like these like really heavy glass I
mean excuse me it's really
um thick heavy not plastic but like a
Bakelite or something heavy uh material
on it
that's my best guess so that would have
been to the left and then to the right
would have been the the very end of the
bar that you just saw a picture of
all right let's go to 1821 defendants
and do you recognize what's depicted in
this photo yes that's the bar that I was
just talking about okay now I see a
phone on the right side is that the
phone you were talking about no that's
not this is a wall mounted phone that's
a landline
and
you see straight ahead at the very if
you look straight ahead at the picture
on the top part of that it appears to be
some broken glass do you recall
what do you recall of that
I recall more than just this window
being broken this is one of the windows
that he broke when he was throwing
things at me my my body was standing in
front of that little kitchen sink you
see at the end of the picture
um I suppose that's some of the glass I
felt though on the backs of my arms
um like when I when when the window
shattered
let's go to 18 22.
18 22 I don't have it in evidence 1822
is not inevitable that's exactly why I
just went over here let's go to 18
25 I think is that the next one you're
on 1825 is an Evidence okay
do you recognize this picture
yes that's where Johnny was standing uh
when I found him the the last morning
that morning it might have been like
midday when I say morning it was after I
woke up
um it was certainly not early morning
um
and he was standing at that desk behind
the desk with the Manson blaring
when when I
found him and told him that I was going
to call
um
9-1-1 if he didn't call Jerry
if you look in this picture there
appears to be a lampshade down below do
you recognize that lampshade down below
the table
that's uh one of the Lampshades Johnny
wrote
um
threats or messages to me um
okay
then let's go to 1827
do you recognize this
yes I do that's my painting Studio
so when I walk downstairs and
saw all the all the blood on the walls I
walked into this room first that's where
the the stairs empty into this room and
kind of my
painting area and those are the canvases
that he
um
repainted
and do you see if you look by the white
the white tablecloth table to the right
of that do you see a lampshade there
yes I don't know if that's the same
lampshade or another one okay
and let's go to 1828
and do you
recognize what's in that one
I do
those are my were
my paintings
um
that
I don't I don't know when he did that if
it was before or after the writing on
the walls but
just
ruin them
so I just want to make sure so the
painting canvas that's dark colored
there's two of them there well there's
yeah there's
two or three and then there's a smaller
one in the in in the center and that was
um
uh his daughter I was trying to paint a
portrait of and that was untouched
okay and then but but just so we're
clear the one directly in front of you
that looks like it's just a lot of dark
colors
was that dark colors before or
I am objection your honor leading
I said was that dark colors before I'll
sustain the objection uh what if any
change was there on that canvas
oh I'm I'm a terrible painter but I'm
not that bad I was
not my painting it was um the start of a
portrait and
um
he changed it
dramatically
okay and then to the right side on the
other side of more to the right than the
one you already testified to
is that what that picture looked like
before or is that objection leading
what if any changes were there to that
picture
well the the three canvases
um were portraits so they looked similar
to the one that's in the center that I
was doing of his daughter
and the white that's below what if any
changes were there to that the white
canvas that you see there it just looks
like the painting was it looks like once
he destroyed objection calls for
speculation sorry
interesting was there anyone else in the
house besides Mr Depp and you
not that I know of no and no one was
around
okay
do you have any reason to believe
somebody other than Mr Depp did this
objection leading
what if any
what if any reason do you believe that
Mr Depp did this objection I I was not
what offended what's what's happening
overrule that objection thank you
um it was just Johnny and I in the house
over the course of those three days
roughly and there might have been
somebody
his assistant or something come on on
the first day or second day I can't
recall but uh for the majority of the I
mean for the entirety of what I've been
describing to you it was Johnny and I in
that house
and did you do any of this did you
create any of this damage no
um I'm also gonna
take a look at the white tablecloth to
the right there and also Johnny was
covered in paint so
to answer your question fully
um that's also how I know
so I'm also just going to draw your
attention to that white tablecloth over
there
does it appear to have some
paint on that as well
yes there is paint
all over the place to say it plainly
no the painting that you indicated there
was a a large penis I believe where was
that I believe it was just
like if you're looking at this I believe
it was on the wall almost right next to
the painting directly Center that we're
looking at that's my best recollection
but I can't be entirely sure okay
let's go to 18 28.
I think that was 1828
oh 18 29 my apologies
and do you recognize this photo
yes I do
and
what was this
um this is one of the
lampshades
that Johnny chose as medium to leave me
messages
in Blood and pain okay
let's go to 1830
do you recognize this
yes that's one of the bathroom mirrors
okay
and if you could just look to the left
and I'm going to go ahead and circle it
over here
you see
red and black there do would you agree
yes okay
um
and there were some questions that were
asked earlier about that red what if
anything did you write on this mirror I
didn't write anything on the mirrors I
was it's confused as anyone in hearing
that testimony
um and based on looking at this area
that I have circled
um is is the black on top or underneath
the red objection honor culture
speculation leading
that's a standard objection
right you know this might be a good time
to take a break why don't we go ahead
okay and take our afternoon break ladies
and let's go ahead and have our uh break
do not discuss the testimony with
anybody and don't do any outside
research we'll come back here if
all right in 15 minutes
all right so we'll come back at 402 okay
thank you all right thank you
oh yeah
foreign
thank you
okay all back thank you all right before
we get the jury I want to see uh talking
with Sammy is Friday May 27th it's not
we just don't meet on Fridays but is
that a okay day to have trial on that
Friday it's the day it's the Friday
before Memorial Day
I want to check with the jury but I want
to check with you first yes that'll
actually be closing argument day for
anybody that wants to know okay so right
so I just want to make sure that keeps
on track but if it's good with the jury
I just want to make sure that that
Friday is good it works for me okay
okay
sure
thank you
foreign
ER Michelle if you can bring back up 18
30 for a moment
18 30. I'm sorry
Amber we were talking about this right
before the break
um
still has my highlight
which color is underneath the other
objection
calls for speculation
chicken
based on your perception which color is
under sustain the objection
all right let's do this let's bring up
defendants 375 which is already into
evidence
I think I need to clear that highlight
your honor but I don't have the control
on mine there we go thank you
each in the top right corner if you need
it but that's fine thank you oh there it
is my menu was hidden
um
Amber I'm going to ask you ask you to
take a look at this is the picture that
we saw earlier
and do you see the area that's written
in red here yes okay what if anything
did you have to do with the writing of
that red
nothing do you
before this trial did you know who Carly
Simon was
um I might have heard her music but
no I didn't okay
okay did you know what songs Carly Simon
wrote or sang No you had to tell me
all right and then if you can just
remember this picture this picture again
the red area there that I've circled and
then I'm going to ask Michelle to take
this one down and put 18 30 back up
and I'm gonna ask you to take a look at
this
did you what if anything did you do to
this mirror with respect to the black or
the red
I I didn't touch it
and
what if any pictures did you take
I took a picture of
the it was the picture we had right
before this is the one I took because it
was in the bathroom where I found my
clothes in the tub and stuff like that
and that's let's go to 374 please
that's already in evidence
is that the picture you're referring to
uh yes it is okay and I'm sorry I just
want to make sure that I understand what
else was in this bathroom where this
mirror was
uh the bathtub and another mirror which
also had writing on it uh the bathtub
had a few of my clothes in it and paint
and both of the two mirrors were painted
I believe I took a picture of both
mirrors
okay
and then I'm going to ask you Michelle
if you can bring us back to 1831.
and did you take this picture
no okay and do you see in the mirror
there can you see the bathtub in the
back there
yes I can all right was that the bathtub
that you're referring to yes it is okay
okay and that had your clothes in it
objection leading I'm sorry what if
anything did it have in the bathtub a
few of my uh clothes with paint on them
uh you can see him I I think that's what
I see up in the corner of the mirror
okay and then let's go to 377 for a
moment that was in
evidence already
and
do you recall seeing this picture
earlier
I do okay
okay and now let's go to 1829 please
does that appear to be the same
lampshade but in color
it does appear that okay it is thank you
all right now let's just go through I'm
going to ask you to take a look at 1834
and what does this depict that you can
recall
and that is the TV that Johnny threw uh
the cup of coffee at
okay and let's go to 18 35.
foreign
one of the sofas in the living room
next to the kitchen
with blood on it okay
and then let's go to 1837.
and what does this depict
to one of the guest bedrooms with
Johnny's iPad on the bed and blood and
or paint on the
on the duvet cover
all right thank you now let's do 1838
what does this depict
a lampshade or a lamp that has been
robbed of the shade okay
let's go to 1839
what does this depict another a
different bed with more blood on it
then let's go to 1840.
and what does this depict
blood on one of the guitars that Johnny
was apparently trying to play
okay
okay then you didn't try to play
objection your honor speculation
I didn't even get the words at this
point next your question okay what if
any effort did you make to make to play
a guitar I've never played the guitar
okay
let's go to 1841
what is this depict
uh it is where Johnny slammed the end of
a bottle
into the wall
wall um
holding me up against it
is it is this in the bar area
I'm
hopping in two rooms so it's hard to
tell the bottle into the wall
um
the best of my recollection happened in
the um kitchenette bar area downstairs
but I can't be 100 certain
okay and let's go to 1842.
what does this depict
Another Broken lamp
okay
and then I've just got a few more left
1805.
and what is this depict wine spell it
looks like a the remnants of a a wine
glass being thrown
[Music]
um
and it looks like a broken glass
do you recognize where this was in the
house
well it looks like a bedside table but I
can't be certain okay
let's go to 1806.
all right
let's um do you know let's let's skip
that one and let's go to 1808.
do you know what this depicts uh wine
spell
okay
all right
now you
started to
testify
about what before we go there
in these pictures would you say they
accurately depict
the damage that you saw that third
morning no
what else what why how were they not
accurately depicting
well
if
you can believe it this is a significant
it seems significantly cleaned up
there was much more uh damage
specifically broken glass
on the countertops there was a lot of
broken glass I could feel it cutting my
arms when I was trying to get up
um and I could feel it underneath my
feet so
I I don't I don't know when these
pictures were taken but um there's been
some cleanup
no you indicated that the uh
that Johnny had had turned on your
iPhone and recorded is that correct yes
did there come a time that you
discovered a recording on your iPhone
from Australia yes much later there was
this
five hour long recording and naturally I
didn't know what that could possibly be
because even though Johnny and I
recorded each other
often
as part of our
you know struggles to figure out our
relationship
[Music]
um
this one was you know five hours was
unusual and that's when I discovered
that that there had been this recording
of the end of
the Australia incident
if if you will and did you listen to
that recording I have heard it yes and
and does it accurately represent what
was depicted in that recording objection
form
lack of foundation
you're going to approach I'm not sure
can you tell me the number of that the
exhibit number sorry 378. thank you
thank you Adam thank you
remember you testified that you made
arrangements to return home can you
describe let's take you to at the point
you left the Australia house uh to go to
the airport and we're accompanied by Ben
King could you tell the jury what
transpired during that period of time
so I
I left Australia shortly after that
my understanding with Johnny was in the
hospital first finger
and Ben King was going to accompany me
and on the ride
on the way to the airport
uh Johnny calls me
and
we were just crying on the phone
where he was crying
uh
he asked if it was
if if he had killed it if he meaning the
relationship it was uh remember the
exact words that he
used but it was kind of asking me in
that in that way is it done is this over
did we kill it
did I kill it
that sort of thing I I don't I don't
remember what I was saying to him but we
hung up as I went into the airport
[Music]
um
I I would I had a mix of feelings I just
nothing really was making perfect sense
to me for sure and I flew back with Ben
I don't really remember speaking to Ben
on the on the flight
okay
do you
um
when Mr debb was what you testified on
on Mr Witten Mr Depp said to you on the
phone right were you on the phone with
anyone else or was it just Mr Depp you
were on the phone with
I only remember speaking to Johnny and I
remember sitting in the back seat of the
SUV that had driven
me and we were outside of the
entrance where you walk into the airport
and I
even then felt
torn
about leaving
I obviously didn't want to stay but
I was in such shocking you're on or
non-responsive
all right I don't know how that's
non-responding we've got to ask your
question again okay
um
please tell us how you felt at that
point and and uh what Mr Depp was saying
to you
I remember
um projection honor Austin answered
she was in the middle of responding to
it your honor or what you're understood
it was a different question about
assisting that objection if you want to
ask a question okay how did you feel at
that time
I felt destroyed
like my heart was broken
I didn't know what to do
I thought maybe
if I left
him in Australia I thought maybe
something would happen to him
I thought he might die or kill himself
because it certainly seems like the
trajectory he was on
he told me he had put a cigarette out on
his face
before
the Friday before
and combined with all the uh when I was
in the bedroom
and he was in the hospital
I found and I was packing my bags and
stuff I found all these empty bags of
coke bags you know dime bags with white
residue on them
I'm in them
um they were in books
in the bedside table I I and there were
so many that I was like I wondered how I
didn't see it before even though I had
you know just gotten there
so I was worried he would die and I was
worried that we couldn't come back from
what happened
I was worried that
there was just no way to
turn this around there was no going back
but
shock shock
so you
flew out of that airport did you have to
uh did you have a stop anywhere before
you went back to LA
objection and relevance
uh yes we did we stopped in um
in an airport
I think it was uh we stopped at the
Sydney Airport from Brisbane I believe
and did you have to change Gates there
yes
um
I
we had a short flight to get to Sydney
and then in Sydney I walked with Ben
through the airport to get the next
plane and we passed a new stand
and I just remember
um I passed this new stand and there was
a book on the
on you know on one of the book stands
outside of the store and it had this uh
puzzle piece on it and
it Johnny and I used to
use that as a term of endearment puzzle
piece you know
um
and I saw this puzzle piece on the cover
of the book got my attention said four
ways to click a relationship guide
so I bought it and I who was the author
Dr Amy Banks okay
go ahead please continue
so the book at least from the subtitles
that it
was a um a book on solving relationship
problems
so I bought it and I read it on the way
home
and why did you buy it and read it on
the way home
because I loved this man
I love this man so much
and it was
so toxic
and for some reason I couldn't get him
to
I couldn't get him to
not hurt me I don't I could
and it seemed like I was hurting him but
we love each other loved each other
so much at least I loved him so much
and I didn't know what to do I didn't
know what to do with this relationship
this is awful and toxic but it was so
important to me and I loved him so much
I
I would have read a million books
so when you got back to
la
how long before Mr Depp came back
a few days Johnny came back within a few
days
he went to his
Suites her house the main house which
was what we did you know if there was a
problem between Johnny and I we weren't
under the same roof once
you know the fight had either paused or
ended depending but he would he would go
to Sweet sir and I would stay at the ECB
and so he went to Switzer Pond landing
and there was some
conversations with the medical team you
know doctors and stuff and I just
remember feeling
concern for his life because things had
changed and
without saying what they said to me it
objection your honor hearsay
she said without saying she's
characterizing it well I'll rule for now
we'll see where we go
um
I was I became really really worried
that uh
Johnny was
not going to live through this that
there would be infections or problems
and things and he wouldn't stop using
Coke and he couldn't get the surgery he
needed because he wouldn't stop using
Coke and they wouldn't put him under
because of all the coke so it's actually
on her hearsay
all right
okay all right next question so when did
you next
uh
committee when did you next see Mr Depp
after you got back from Australia
I saw him a few days
I don't know how long it was but it was
as a doctor I think my best recollection
is that it was in the doctor's office or
around that he needed a procedure
did there come a time that you
reconciled after Australia
yes because it
it almost felt like
it it went away
so quickly because
there was this surgery that he needed
and
there was a maybe a few maybe he had
more than one surgery but it was you
know like it became very very about
getting Johnny through the next step
you know getting Johnny home getting
Johnny off the coke long enough to get
the procedure done and then get after
that procedure getting another procedure
John and it was just these small steps
and before you know it we were kind of
back in it
um with the prospect of course of him
being done with
with all the drugs and drinking because
that's what necessarily had to happen
for him to have this surgery
so that made me feel a little
you know a little bit more secure and
and kind of
coming back into this relationship with
him
so I'm going to take you to March 23
2015.
just a few weeks after two and a half
weeks roughly after Australia
um
where was Johnny staying at this point
I
I think he was staying at the Eastern
Columbia I mean at the ECB
um
yeah he was staying at the ECB
at the time because we were
kind of in the bedroom together the
night of the 22nd
which is when he passed out how I found
his iPad
I'm sorry when you
I I found his iPad open he was texting
someone with the open he passed out
and I saw what he was texting please
tell the jury about that
uh he was
he was texting this woman
that he had had a relationship with on
and off
um
kind of at the beginning of our
relationship so I recognized the name
but the date was right after the wedding
I saw he had gone to her house
after we got married like upon touching
down in Los Angeles I think it was the
next day he
went to This Woman's house like
his sexual relationship with
and
um what did you what did you do as a
result of seeing that on the iPad
I freaked out
I immediately like confronted him about
it I was
you know
I I didn't care in that moment
if
he did kill me which was
likely in confronting him at that stage
of Our Lives
I didn't even care anymore at this
moment I was he had already ripped my
heart out you know this like I've just
been through what I
after having been through what I
went through in Australia
just weeks prior I see this it was like
foreign
ly painful unbelievably painful
so
what did you do
I I'm yelling at him
so just yelling I called I was calling
him all these ugly names I was screaming
at him
told me to get the [ __ ] out of the house
is what I said excuse my language but
we were screaming at each other
at some point we were
upstairs and Penthouse three and
we kind of get into a
how do you describe it
um
pushing each other you know
and I just remember
um
being so
mad at him
for
for
cheating
on me and doing so in this way like
right after the wedding and then I right
after my wedding go to see him and then
Australia happens and it just felt like
everything came crashing down and I was
so hurt
anyway we I break out of his grasp at
some point and I go into my sister's
room the apartments and the ECB are
connecting at least three of them are
and they connect from upstairs only so
you could get from Johnny and I's
apartment into the neighboring apartment
where Whitney my sister was staying at
the time
and then you could go from that
apartment into
Penthouse five again still on on the top
floor
so I went through Johnny's office which
is how you access the door that gets you
into Whitney
the neighboring apartment where Whitney
was my sister
and I went in there and woke her up
crying screaming saying what am I gonna
do okay
sorry all right I'll sustained I don't
know that was diver to prove the truth
of the matter
okay so you went to Whitney's don't tell
the jury what you said to her about what
happened next
um
uh Johnny comes into penthouse for
and
um
grabs me I don't know what why I don't
know what he was
doing
um but at one moment I
um kind of
I'm aware that my sisters
somewhere nearby and I I thought about
that I just remember thinking about that
and he
um
I I remember getting kind of free from
from Johnny and
and he left or he walked out of the room
when you say free from Johnny what if
any connection did you have the physical
connection before that well I mean I'm
you know trying to
stand up for myself and
Johnny Wood I thought stage in our
relationship it was he would just
throw me shove me hit me in the face I
mean it was just like all I could do is
just try to
try to fight back or try to
not get more hurt
than
not doing anything would have certainly
left me
I don't really recall
um specifics I I I remember at one point
he had his uncasted hand in my hair and
I was looking at the carpet
I don't know
I don't know what happened immediately
after that but I remember he left he was
out of the room for a while
I don't know how we got into
I think I heard him in P5 again this is
the neighboring apartment of that so
there's P4 in between MP5 is the the
corner and that apartment was empty
basically and so the the I used it the
top bedrooms the the bedrooms on the top
floor is my closet and had all these
clothing racks and shoe racks and stuff
like that in there
and then it had another level the
mezzanine which is an over you know it
hung over the rest of the bottom floor
uh and I use that as my office
and the bottom floor is of course the
living room with just some sparsely
decorated just some big couches and a
low table
and I
um go on to I hear him in
um Penthouse five
and oh and the lower level also is
another painting Studio like painting
area of mine so I go in there because I
hear him
and he's screaming but I don't know why
I don't know who he's I I
my my understanding was to be screaming
at me but I wasn't in that apartment
I could hear him and when I heard him
uh I I came into the
into Penthouse five and I have to go
down the stairs and and I went down the
stairs to the mezzanine level where my
office was and I could see him and uh a
security guard and Debbie the nurse and
he was sitting on the on the sofa
um at when I first walked into the room
and he kind of stood up he was drinking
a Red Bull and screaming at me and
Debbie came up the stairs because
I'm screaming back at him she came up
the stairs I think
and while we were she came up I I'm
supposed to kind of comfort me and while
I was up on the mezzanine floor Whitney
came down
and
um he threw the Red Bull can up at
me certainly but it kind of either hit
or narrowly missed Debbie
um
and I said he I called him a [ __ ]
and and said something about you know
I'm screaming at him angrily
um
I I at least called him a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know what else I said but I was
screaming at him because he threw this
can at me and everything else that had
happened
and when I did that he bolted up the
stairs
and
you know there's only I mean he
he was up he was up the first flight of
stairs again I'm on the mezzanine which
is in between two flights of stairs
he bolted up the steps
and I I don't know
I don't know how he managed to get his
hands in my hair so fast but he had his
hand on the back of my my head my hair
and kind of was yanking me down and hit
me in the face with this cast he had
um I just remember this this
brief struggle we had before kind of
breakaway Whitney my sister
um
all of a sudden put herself
in between Johnny and I
she just threw herself
like in the line of fire or whatever she
just
all of a sudden was there was trying to
get Johnny to stop
um her back was to the staircase
and
Johnny swings at her
and I just
see my little sister with her back face
her back to the staircase
and Johnny swings at her and I don't
even wait
don't even wait for
any other I don't hesitate I don't wait
I just in my head instantly think of
Kate Moss and the stairs and I
swung in him
in all of my relationship to date with
Johnny
I hadn't landed a blow
and I for the first time hit him like
actually hit him
Square in the face
he didn't push my sister down the stairs
and all of my time
all my time
of being in that relationship to that
point
I hadn't even landed one on Johnny
sure I tried to fight back through my
arms flailed my arms hit whenever I I
could to try to block blows myself but
never landed anything
and
Johnny kind of looked stunned and then
laughed at me
and then lunged at me again and before I
Know It uh security
stepped in between us and and and and
and and pulled Johnny away
uh and I went upstairs with my sister
and
um
we locked the the door and I could just
hear all this commotion happening in
Penthouse five I could hear him raging
destroying my things I could hear it
um and at some point I saw it the next
day
tell the jury what you saw the next day
um what
um
all these clothing wrap all my clothing
racks were toppled over shoe racks
toppled over thrown down the stairs
um desk everything on my desk wiped off
just look like everything that he could
touch he
tried to
turn over destroy smash you know but my
clothing racks these huge heavy clothing
racks full of clothes
uh there was at least one of them he
threw down the stairs the rest were
toppled over
Amber I'm going to fast forward to
December 15 2015.
[Music]
um
were you and Mr Depp together at that
time
yes we were
did did you have a fight that night
uh December 15th yes we did but I I
don't recall
I don't recall what started the argument
we had had periods leading up to that
that were really beautiful and really
good and then periods that were
well let's talk about the December 15
2015.
what do you recall of your fight that
night with Mr death
I remember him chasing me
in the kitchen I remember throwing
something in his Direction
to slow down his momentum
I remember him screaming
um
I remember him getting on top of me
at some point toppling me
um
mostly at that moment downstairs he was
hitting me in my face
again this is another example of when I
wish so much I could tell you in a duck
sequence
but I can't it's
flashes
um
so I'll tell you what I do remember
I remember
at some point
um
trying to go flee upstairs and we had
um he got a hold of me and I got free
and I managed to get all the way up the
stairs almost I was on the last flight
and
um
we had some interaction where I I said I
think I said something to him on the
stairs
it might have been broken up and I think
I said something on the stairs and I
just remember how quickly he shot back
up those stairs and
um grabbed me by the back of my hair my
head and slammed his
um his hand on my head
and I went down on the stairs and he
overtook me
I remember him so well I remember his
boots and the sound they made I remember
him grabbing my my hair my head and kind
of dragging me up the stairs the rest
the rest of the way
he dragged me into the the room that
those stairs open into it's like a salon
foyer area
and we had this
argument that kind of
you know was a shoving match that I was
losing
um by the second or third
shove he sent me um toppling over this
sheds Lounge like a little low-lying
sofa seat
and I hit my head on the on the brick
uh wall it was a there was an exposed
brick wall
I remember I stood up and I remember
Johnny
asking me if I wanted to go
and he did that
thing where he's like
challenge like challenging me said it in
that way challenging me to stand up
and get back up and when I did he said
oh you really want to go now tough guy
shoved me back down oh you really want
to go huh oh you're so tough I stood
back up again this time he hits me in
the face
I stand back up and look him right in
the eyes and it was just a really still
moment I'll never forget it really still
I stood up and he said you want to go
again tough guy and I just looked right
at him just looked right at his face
and he balled up his fists
leaned back
and head-butted me Square in the nose
just
right as I stood in front of him
I was
a foot from him
slam me right in the nose instantly
searing pain
it's one of the few memories I have in
this long relationship that I actually
remember
the the like the physical pain in that
moment you know just searing
and
I remember thinking you
you have your hands free
you know like I I had time to think if
you have your hands free you could have
hit me with your hands why did you
headbutt me
I I told him that night I was going to
leave him
I went through his office to go
into the other room where I kept all my
stuff
we had another
um struggle he overtook me
um I was trying to hit him off me I was
trying to get him to get it trying to
get his body off of me and he was just
pummeling me I don't know how else to
describe what I was
foreign
I went down to the floor
I remember being on top of me and he's
screaming and swinging at me while I was
on the floor
he had me by the hair
and dragged me
the rest of the way from the office into
the neighboring room the neighboring
apartment
I remember
um
this the door that connected these two
build these two rooms had a metal uh
great not a great but a metal
bottom metal floor that separated it
it's a big heavy Bank door
and I remember he was dragging me and I
removed my hands from my head
and kind of tried to grab onto the metal
door
to prevent and from dragging me into the
room but he I I I couldn't stop at me
drag me all the way from that carpet I
was I was trying to X I was trying to
get free his grasp I was trying to
stop him from pulling me I remember
feeling the carpet and the metal
and
he wrestles me drags me up to the bed
and throws me down onto the bed it kind
of wrestles me down onto the bed
and he kneels on my back with one one
leg
and I was trying to fight him off me
because I was face down
on the bed top and he wrestled me
down kind of trying to hold me down with
his knee on my back
and he's punching me
punching me with a close fist punching
me
repeatedly and I I don't remember even
feeling the pain
I just remember the sound of Johnny's
voice
he got next to my ear and he was
screaming over and over and over again
each time it sounded louder and more
desperate I [ __ ] hate you I [ __ ]
hate you I [ __ ] hate you over and
over
[ __ ] hate you
and then
pounding the back of my head pounding it
with his fist and I
don't even remember feeling pain I just
could hear myself scream until I
couldn't hear myself anymore
I could just hear him say that he was
going to kill me
and that he sounded like an animal in
pain when he was saying he was that he
[ __ ] hated me
he sounded like he was almost crying or
something in his voice was different he
sounded different like
he sounded like he was in agony
it was high pitched and loud
and I don't know how many times he just
hit me over and over and over again and
I got really still
and it felt in my body like quiet
and
I thought this is how I die
he's gonna kill me now and I'm not
you're gonna kill me and he
won't even have realized it
I couldn't breathe
I remember trying to scream and I
couldn't scream
I was suffocating
in this pillow top
with him holding me down
punching me
over and over and I don't
have any memory after that until I woke
up
when you woke up was there anyone there
I remember
hearing my best friend's voice
I felt like it came
um
I felt like it was like on a
speakerphone like it came from
everywhere I just heard her voice in a
weird way felt like it was coming from
two directions
and I realized that I was sitting on the
edge of the bed on the carpet of the
floor against the
the broken
frame of the bed and there was a
low-lying bed
with a really thick wooden frame
and it was broken from his boot trying
to get a purchase on it
while he was
objection honor culture speculation I
could feel it
overall thank you please continue
I was there for it
um and while he was on top of me I could
feel that I could feel him trying to get
balance I could feel him slipping I
could hear it
I don't know how I got off the bed
I don't know what happened to me
from the time I was I stopped hearing
myself scream I don't know what happened
to me
it's a really weird feeling because I
next thing I remember is laying leaning
against the broken part of the bed
and on the carpet and I my friend saying
oh my God I'm touching your honor
hearsay sustained okay
go ahead and then I what Rocky said I I
I
eventually
um she called uh the nurse nurse Aaron
um
she got something out of the freezer for
my face
she did a concussion track with Aaron on
the phone
um
I I I thought I probably had a
concussion
and certainly thought I had a broken
nose
was blood everywhere blood all over
those pillows
um
my head was bleeding from the ripped out
hair chunks of hair on the floor all
over the place actually it was just all
over the apartment
he
after leaving me had written on the
countertops
in Sharpies
Michelle I'm going to ask you to bring
up defendants exhibit 510
.
do you recognize this photograph
yes I do
and does it accurately depict the scene
portrayed
yes that's um the next day I think yeah
I'm going to move the admission of
defendants exhibit 510 no objection all
right 510 evidence you can publish it
please
and could you describe to the jury what
that is
um
chunks my hair Johnny ripped out
while dragging me
uh and punching me
thank you Michelle could you bring up
513 please defendants 513.
hello
does this picture accurately depict
you
in in the scene portrayed
I think this is a couple days later but
yeah okay I'm gonna move the admission
of defendants 513.
no objection all right 513 in evidence
and could you tell the jury what this is
and what it depicts
this is um my face
um with
a busted lip which it's difficult to see
in this picture but
um
my two black eyes one is worse than the
other
like I said maybe a day or two later
um and
my
broken nose
all right thank you Michelle can you
bring up defendants exhibit 514
does this accurately portray the scene
depicted
yes that's my face
sometime after
your honor I'm going to move the
admission of defendants 5 14. no
objection 514 Netherlands being
published
all right if you could just briefly
describe for the jury what this one is
um
that's my face
uh some
time after
um
and Tony beat me up
thank you Michelle if you could bring up
defendants 515
is this accurately portrayed the scene
depicted
yes
I'm going to move the admission of
exhibit 516. objection 5 15 or 5 16. I'm
5 16. I'm sorry if I misspoke you said 5
15 before
5
15.
no objection to 515 okay 5 15 in
evidence
and what does this
depict Amber could you tell the Jew this
is my face
of
sometime after
all right let's look at defendants 516
please
this accurately
portrayed the scene depicted
Amber yes it does this is maybe wait
wait let me let me move it first may I
move the admission of defendants exhibit
516. no objection 5 16 is evidence
published to the jury please
okay Amber go ahead and explain what it
is
I think this is um
maybe the that night or the next night
after
um Johnny left me on the bed
let's go to 517.
does this accurately portray the scene
depicted
yes it does move to admit defendants 517
your honor no objection 517 evidence
Amber please describe for the jury what
this portrays
um that's my face after
this
incident
right and what is what's portrayed on
your lip
um well he busted my lip when he punched
me
it's bleeding in this picture it kept
reopening you know it's a mouth the lips
move
go to 5 19.
is this accurately portray the scene
depicted
and tell the jury what this shows
uh this is my lip a few days later
let's go to defendants 520 please
is this accurately depict the scene
portrayed
yes move the admission of defendants 520
is it 521
520. no objection 520 in evidence about
can you please tell the jury what's
depicted here
that's my
scalp
with a chunk of it missing
from when
Johnny
was tracking by my hair
let's go to defendants 521 please
foreign
let's take that one down let's go to
522.
does this accurately portray the scene
depicted
well it's a few days later okay
move the admission of 522 please no
objection 5.2 in advance
and what shows there
my face is healing
okay
let's go to 523
does this accurately portrayed this
scene depicted
yes I think this is
day or so after maybe maybe longer I
can't tell but
yes it does move the admission of 523.
no objection 5 23 minutes
I'm just gonna draw your attention Amber
to an area up here what if any uh
bruising did you sustain in that area
objection leading what if any I'll
sustain the objection okay
um
it's what if any bruising did you
sustain right same objection
sustain the objections did you did
what injuries did you have
I had bruising on my temple my chin
um the my neck the back of my head I had
um swelling and pieces of you know my
scalp kind of ripped torn they were
gross [ __ ] but this is of um the
bruising around my temple
from one of the blows one several of the
Blues I don't know
let's go to 524
this is accurately portray the scene
shown yes okay move the admission to
524. no objection 24 and evidence
and what does this show
and some I had a pretty
can I touch the screen yes yes ma'am you
can yes and I had a pretty
um
gross bruise right there in my
my head on my temple
it's difficult to see it in this light
but I remember it was pretty
ugly
now let's go to defendants 509
does this accurately portray the scene
depicted
yes it does you're going to remove the
admission of defendants 509
no objection all right 509.
will you please tell the jury what this
is
that's the bed that Johnny broke
while on top of me
all right let's go to defendants 511
please
does this accurately portray the scene
depicted
yes move the admission of defendants
511. no objection all right five eleven
in evidence
what do you see in this picture Amber
um just more destruction
from a part of the fight that happened
in the bedroom
not the bedroom that I was um
just talking about
it was uh the main bedroom
there had been a
part of the fight that happened in there
too
go to defendants 512 please
is this accurately portray the scene
depicted
yes um that's downstairs in the main
right let me let me move the admission
of it move the admission of defendants
512 please
no objection 512 in evidence
okay now please tell the jury about it
at uh downstairs in the main apartment
okay
let's go to defendants 525
and does this accurately
depict the scene portrayed
yes move the admission of 525 please no
objection all right 5 25 and evidence
and please tell the jury what this is
this is um Johnny's graffiti on our
kitchen counter
that he left up when he on his way out I
suppose
and I think defendants 526 is already
into evidence could you just bring that
up 526 isn't evidence
okay
now Amber after
as of December 15 2015
what were your plans for Christmas that
year
well uh up to this point the plan was to
have our families join us we would go
with the kids and celebrate
Christmas together you know as a married
couple
and we would all go to Johnny's Island
and he had invited
my best friend at the time Rocky
and her family meaning her mom and her
fiance
and my parents
and my sister and we were all going to
go to this island I've told you about
that Johnny has in the Bahamas
and spend it together and that was a
plan leading up to this
and what if anything changed as a result
of this night of December 15 2015.
after
they saw my face no one wanted to go to
the island anymore with Johnny
they wanted me to leave him
did you have to appear were you
scheduled to appear on the James Corden
show on December 16th
that's right I was promoting the Danish
girl the film I had done earlier in the
year in London
before going to see Johnny in Australia
so I was promoting that film that had
been completed and they asked me to make
an appearance on a
a night show called The James Corden
show
after this happened and I did the first
concussion check with Aaron on the phone
I
I got worried that I wouldn't be able to
hide the bruising and swelling
um
but I
iced it all night and the next day
um
checked in the mirror to see if I could
get away with it
meaning hiding it
so I can make an appearance
and
I I gambled and thought maybe I could
pull it off
I had my hair and makeup team come
and they worked around it meaning
worked around the
lesions on my head with the hairspray
because that stings
and
worked around the
the bruising by covering it with heavy
makeup heavy or makeup than normal
bruise covering makeup
and I remember my lip was
still bleeding and swollen so we did
this like really thick super heavy matte
red lipstick
you know I remember very well at the
time that
we had no choice in color and that was a
a one of my favorite colors to wear and
in this occasion we had no choice
because nothing else would hide
my busted lip
and I went on the show
did what I always do
I told people I had an accident
objection your honor hearsay all right
sustained you that offered to prove the
truth doesn't matter but she didn't have
an accident I was staying the objection
okay please continue so did you appear
on the show I appeared on the show
and did there come a time that you
changed your mind and went to the
Bahamas with Mr Depp for Christmas
eventually 15. eventually I did
and you went there with whom
I I went with Johnny's kids
I was a
you know
obviously I didn't see Johnny after this
because he doesn't
he didn't face the damage he caused in
my experience
he was never around for the cleanups and
uh so he wasn't around for a few days
and I
eventually heard from him and he said he
wanted to talk
and then he understood that
it couldn't
go back you know like almost as if he
understood that I wouldn't forgive him
made it easier from how to talk to him
you know I didn't feel so bad about
myself
in that
case because you know
how could I put up with this right
but with the understanding that we were
done
I could you know
allow for us to
have one last conversation I suppose
but I just
you know it's like um
I was heartbroken by the idea that I
would spend this my first Christmas as a
married couple with his kids and
everything on the island I I was
heartbroken at the idea of missing that
and
you know it's the best I can describe it
is it's like um for every
every hit every instance of violence
every time I was choked every single one
of these instances was
like a heavy coin
put into a piggy bank and you know you
you think okay well each single one of
these is like
objection your honor non-responsive
yeah I think it's responsive the
question was with whom did you go
if we could ask the question all right
tell us how you felt and what you were
thinking in this process of whether to
go to have Christmas with Mr Depp and
his children
you know I guess I was trying to explain
go ahead go ahead
that you know just after you think each
one of these is um
it's almost like you for each one of
these things that happens
you lose the will
or resolve to leave you know it's like
every single
heavy coin you put in this piggy bank is
like an investment into the future
you're going to get to you know and then
before you know it you're just carrying
around this weighted ball this piggy
bank is too heavy you can't leave
you know for every single time
I went back or allowed him back
after this sort of thing would happen
I lost a piece of
my
self
a piece of my self-confidence
my
trust in myself to leave and move on
you know this
I lost fortifications I lost myself
and
it was somehow easier to stay
I didn't want
to stay in the violence or in this
I wanted to stay with Johnny
the good Johnny
that I loved
so I
like put another one of those coins in
the piggy bank of investment in Hope and
future and
I forgive him
not
it wasn't even that simple I just
decided to believe him that it would
never happen again the clean and sober
once again this time was the last time
because it couldn't be worse than this
right it couldn't be worse
and part of me we thought maybe it just
needed to get this bad to get you know
like now we can't go back that there's
no way this could happen again
so I I went to the island after a few
days of
talking
with Johnny arguing with Johnny talking
with Johnny negotiating that it's going
to be clean and sober I wasn't going to
drink anymore he wasn't going to use
anymore he'd never lay a hand on me
again he'd rather die than do that is
what he was saying and
I was scared my friends were scared but
I decided to go
after a few days of having the plane and
the kids waiting not knowing what was
going on they were at Sweet sir the main
house kind of just waiting to go on this
Christmas Vacation
and eventually
um I I got in the car with Johnny
and we picked his kids up and left for
the island
so
let's let's go to the island
for the Christmas holidays and what if
any
uh
arguments did you have with Mr Depp at
the island over the Christmas holiday
towards the end of the trip
it was I mean the trip itself was pretty
nice but towards the end
he started drinking again
and started with wine
and we were on the couch in the main
house a cabin it's like a one-room kind
of cabin
and we were sitting on the couch and
Johnny what what I perceived as nodding
off
I don't still know what it was but he
was kind of passing out or nodding off
or something like that
and I'm sensitive at this point to the
clues that I can pick up on to know what
pattern of behavior I'm dealing with
because they made a huge difference in
my life so if I knew what he was on and
what he was doing I could react
accordingly so I'm picking up Clues I'm
sitting next to him and he's nodding off
and every single time he kind of like
nods off he dumps his glass of wine on
my lap and I say every single time
because it happened three times
first time whatever second time
I'm like Johnny are you all right and I
probably say it like
a little
weighted
and in my head I'm just wondering what
he's on is this does this mean he's on
the roxies again is this like is it
nodding off what's going on what am I
gonna deal with he just had promised
that it was clean and sober we had had
this horrible thing happen in December I
thought we were moving forward
and the third time
as happens
I jump up I already changed my pants
twice
and um
I jumped up and I um shouted Johnny like
you know what are you doing or you or
Johnny
plummy again something's
to that effect
and I get up
okay
um get up off the couch and Johnny's son
says objection your honor here not
offered to prove the truth of the matter
it tells it explains what's coming give
you a good approach I just don't know
foreign
Amber please continue Jack
said it says um are you okay or can I
help
immune to that effect and I
pointedly say
to Jack but really to Johnny like thank
you Jack
and to make a point at the fact
that he hadn't offered to help me or
even acknowledge that he had been
spilling wine first he's drinking wine
second he's spilling it all over me and
30's spilling it because he's nodding
off is what I assume
so I kind of say this in a pointed way
at Jack thanking him
for offering
and I
get up go to the closet
take off the pants that have just been
ruined and
Johnny comes into the closet right after
me
and slams me up against the side of the
closet
and in I mean just with
clarity
with holding my neck
he said he'd [ __ ] kill me if I ever
spoke to him like that in front of his
kids again if I ever embarrass him and
he just
he just shoved me and embarrassed
I ever embarrass you if if you ever
embarrass me again
in front of my kids I'll [ __ ] kill
you
and
I don't know I don't recall who told
Jack to leave or I don't really recall
having an awareness
[Music]
um
of where he was at this point but I
leave the closet and go into the
bathroom which is right next to it
and he comes barreling into the bathroom
behind me
before he does that I said something
snarky to him
and [ __ ] ever talk to me like that
again or I hate you or something
in response you know just something
so that I felt like I
wasn't just being a punching bag
and
I kind of like Get over to the bathroom
but I didn't even have the door shut
before he was in the bathroom with me
and I don't know if you use my body
um to shut the door or or if he just
shut it
but um again
brings me up against the wall
but this time he just
grab my
vagina
like
I was wearing this um Peach kind of like
netted kind of style swimming suit
underneath
that's that that's what I had on from
the waist down and he just
grab me
best I can explain it with his um
shoved his fingers and
inside me but through my bathing suit I
didn't like move my bathing suit out of
the way
and just kind of held me there
and asked me if I was so [ __ ] tough I
thought I was so [ __ ] tough
said are you tough like a man now are
you some man now
it's kind of taunting me
while jerking me around
and he kind of seemed to do this thing
where he was smiling not
just like teasing me
you know like oh yeah you think you're
so [ __ ] tough now what
now what
I
I'm
I don't know what happened after that I
went I went back into the room or he
went into the room I don't know who went
into the main room first
um
I just remember his hand landing on the
back of my shoulder neck area I remember
trying to get him off of me
um
I don't know
I I don't know what the next thing that
happened was but I do remember I knew I
needed to get away from him
at some point I ran
I ran out of the back door ran out onto
the patio
[Music]
um
it's at some point before I ran
he swung at me but
I don't I don't even remember how much
of an impact it meant
made but I remember running
um
I threw something in his in his
Direction
um
when I was getting away from him
uh I ran down the deck
ran out into the kind of like parking
lot areas gravel parking lot area
outside of the house
and that's my estimation of when Johnny
reached me
um grabbed me by the hair swung me
around
um
I remember he hit my face at least once
but I'm not quite sure in what sequence
was it before I broke away or after I
don't remember I just remember the
lights of the ATV coming up
um the island you know two of the people
who worked on the island for Johnny CJ
and Tara they pulled up in the ATV I
remember the headlights I remember
separating from him
or that them kind of running up and
saying something and separating us
and uh
and and I didn't see Johnny for the rest
of the evening as my recollection
I just found him the next day
um
passed out in the cafe that was close to
the house
it's at the end of yeah this is a good
Breaking Point yes all right
okay ladies and gentlemen you can just
stay there for a moment all right ladies
and gentlemen we're going to be breaking
again this is the time that we break for
a week okay so I won't be seeing you
until May 16th but I wanted to talk to
you a little bit about how the remainder
of the case will progress okay all right
so
um we promised to get you the case to
you by Memorial Day so uh in order to
keep that promise there's going to be a
few things I need from you okay one
thing is starting on May 16th we're
going to start having court at 9 00 a.m
so we'll be going 9 A.M to 5 p.m some
days we might have to go to 5 30. so I
want to let you know ahead of time so
you can plan accordingly okay the other
thing I need from you is Friday May 27th
which is the Friday before Memorial Day
is going to be a court day on that day
we're going to go ahead and have closing
arguments in the case it's going to be
turned over to you for deliberations on
that day okay so I again I want to let
you know ahead of time so you can plan
accordingly so we can get this taken
care of for you okay all right so those
are the announcements I want to make for
you and make sure you had time to to
schedule what you needed to do now I
also want to go over as we always do on
Thursdays
our responsibilities the
responsibilities you have as jurors okay
in this case all right so you're not to
read anything about this case you're not
to watch anything about this case you're
not to listen to anything about this
case this applies to television
newspapers magazines the internet and
any online sites further you're not to
read watch or listen to anything about
this case on any social networking sites
such as Twitter Facebook Instagram
Snapchat
Etc or any similar sites
in addition you must not communicate
with anyone about the case whether in
person over the phone by email text or
instant messaging or by any other
electronic or non-electronic means this
includes friends family co-workers
acquaintances and strangers I also
instruct you that you cannot do any
research or make any inquiries about
this case whether online or by any other
means what you learn about this case is
limited to what you learn in the four
walls of this courtroom when proceedings
are underway okay so please enjoy your
week off get plenty of fresh air and
rest all right and then I'll see you at
9am on Monday May 16th okay all right
thank you
foreign
and uh again ma'am since you're still in
the middle of your testimony you can't
discuss your testimony with anybody to
include your attorneys okay you can you
can step down though and have a seat uh
with your attorneys a few housekeeping
matters I want to take care of
before
we finish
Journeys I won't see you tomorrow for
Friday depositions because we finished
all the depositions I want to thank all
of you for last Friday and staying here
until I think it was nine o'clock at
night but we got them all done and I
really appreciate all your work on that
uh it does mean a lot and now you're
rewarded because you don't have to see
me tomorrow so
um so no more depositions
um what I'd also for planning purposes
though since we're gonna be going nine
to five the the day is going to be a
little different so we'll start at nine
we'll probably break for morning break
between 10 30 and 10 45. we're PR we're
going to break for lunch between 12 30
and 1 30 so I want you to plan
accordingly for that our afternoon break
will probably be between I don't know 3
3 15 to 3 30 maybe even a little later 3
45 we'll see and then uh we'll we'll try
to break at five there may be times when
we might go to 5 30 as I told the jury
so I just want to make sure you know
that since I won't see you tomorrow I
want to go ahead and give you your times
as of this very minute of what you have
used and what what you have left okay
are you ready
Mr Chu's going to try to use it with a
highlighter let's wait
that's right
there we go all right so uh plaintiff
has used 35 hours and six minutes
defendants have used 36 hours and 31
minutes
which means the plaintiff has 26 hours
and 9 minutes left
and the defendant has 24 hours and 44
minutes left okay and just a reminder as
we said from the very beginning once
time is up once your time is up your
time is up if it's in the middle of a
witness I'm going to stop you okay so
make sure I mean the nine to five
schedule when we start back on May 16th
will give us a little buffer but not
much so I will be keeping everyone on
task for those last two weeks so keep
that in mind as well
enjoy the next next week I don't
anticipate I will hear from you for this
next week if there's an emergency I
understand that but just remember what
my definition of an emergency is okay we
all remember that all right great so
other than that does anybody have
anything else for me
a few math questions
Sammy says 24.
if you add 36 hours and 31 minutes and
24 hours and 44 minutes
you get
you get what
is uh
well we'll get we'll see you can get
with Sammy when we're done okay
it's
is it right or wrong
what's that
61.
61 hours and 15 minutes does that add up
then that is right this round word says
I'm right
okay so that's the right time Sammy did
it three times over so I thought that
was right you made him very nervous
um okay so that's good everything else
anything else yes Connor we do have our
uh updated exhibit page that you
requested oh perfect approach that's
fine I think that's something Jamie
needed okay all right we'll get that
all right anything else
we're good all right we'll see you
Monday May 16th 9 A.M right all right
thank you very much